der woche geht es ja um den haushalt des
bundestages der bundesrepublik und heute
wird es besonders spannend denn heute
geht es um die debatte über den etat des
bundeskanzlers und das kanzleramt und
das bedeutet natürlich dann auch
generalaussprache generaldebatte im
deutschen bundestag und das wird
beobachtet und kommentiert von meinem
kollegen gerd joachim von fallois den
ich jetzt in berlin begrüße
vielen dank also die haushaltswoche
immer gleich aufgebaut von dienstag bis
freitag und der mittwochmorgen das ist
der tag wo es zur generaldebatte kommt
der oppositionschef wird hier gleich um
9 uhr beginnen darauf dann der kanzler
antworten obwohl ich auch schon mal
erlebt habe aber das ist lange lange her
zu bonner zeiten dass bundeskanzler
helmut kohl sich über den damaligen
oppositionschef so aufgeregt hat dass er
erst in der sozusagen nächsten runde
gesprochen hat was wiederum seine
presseleute nicht so glücklich stimmte
war damit der kanzler erst gegen mittag
redete und das natürlich für die
agenturen da nicht so toll war aber das
wird olaf scholz heute nicht machen also
er wird als zweiter reden und natürlich
geht es in dieser generaldebatte um die
bilanz der letzten monate der neuen
bundesregierung der ampel regierung aber
vor allen dingen natürlich auch um die
rückschau auf diese große rede von olaf
scholz zeitenwende hat er gesagt das war
am 27 februar und hat das 100 milliarden
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr
angekündigt am wochenende gab es da eine
einigung zwischen den ampel fraktionen
und der cdu/csu den man braucht eine
zweidrittelmehrheit im bundestag und
bundesrat um das grundgesetz zu ändern
und damit die bundeswehr eben diese 100
milliarden ausschöpfen kann seit gestern
abend sind auch zahlen bekannte welche
teilstreitkräfte wie viel geld bekommen
alle darüber möchte ich sprechen mit
meinen beiden gästen heute agnieszka
bürger begrüßen sich herzlich die
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
der bündnisgrünen und florian hahn der
verteidigungspolitische sprecher der cdu
csu bei der generaldebatte erhan ist es
so dass die opposition vorliegen darf
deswegen die erste frage an sie sie
kommen gerade aus dem ausschuss war zu
hören dass die union probleme hat und
die abstimmung die heute morgen im
ausschuss stattfinden sollte über die
verteilung der gelder wohl nochmal
aufhalten will also die union hat keine
probleme sondern schlichtweg so dass es
noch ein paar fragezeichen jetzt in den
details geht gibt insgesamt haben sie
richtig gesagt gab es am wochenende eine
einigung wie tatsächlich und das paket
aussehen könnte allerdings ist es jetzt
so dass man sich mit dem details
beschäftigt und dazu gehört zum beispiel
der wirtschaftsplan das heißt wofür wird
konkret werden die 100 milliarden
ausgegeben hier gibt es erst seit
gestern nachmittag tatsächlich ein
dokument das dem haushaltsausschuss auch
zugegangen ist und somit auch den mit
beratenden gremien wie dem
verteidigungsausschuss und hier sind ein
paar fragezeichen die wollen wir heute
noch klären wir sind wieder komplett die
werden wir mit den beteiligten häusern
und gremien klären und nicht im
fernsehen aber ich bin guter dinge dass
wir insgesamt dieses paket in dieser
woche oder sonst zweifel auch in der
nächsten woche
verabschieden können denn es geht hier
um 100 milliarden dafür werden extra
schulden aufgenommen das kann man nicht
mit heißer nadel stricken sondern das
muss grundsolide sein das ist das was
die bürgerinnen und bürger auch erwarten
frau becker sie haben auch die vorlage
erst gestern bekommen wie die aufteilung
stattfinden soll dann haben sie das mit
ihren verteidigungspolitiker
durchgesprochen und keinerlei probleme
offensichtlich bei den grünen ja wir
haben sehr intensiv beraten haben uns
jedes projekt und jede zahl sehr
gründlich angeguckt und konnten dann
auch abends eine rückmeldung geben dass
wir mit diesem wirtschaftsplan so
einverstanden sind das sind ja probleme
und projekte die wir schon seit jahren
im verteidigungsausschuss diskutiert und
deshalb war ich sehr erstaunt zu hören
heute morgen dass die union
offensichtlich nicht sprechen ist dass
sie es nicht geschafft haben obwohl wir
jetzt so lange verhandelt haben ihre
fraktionen immer druck gemacht hat es
soll schnell gehen irgendwie eine
konsolidierte antwort zu geben
offensichtlich scheint es darum
einigkeit zwischen csu und cdu zu geben
und vielleicht hätte herr merz gestern
abend ich im flieger sitzen soll sondern
sich mal mit dem wirtschaftsplan
beschäftigen müssen 40,9 milliarden sind
vorgesehen für die dimensionen luft
heißt das ein bisschen komisch unter
anderem eben die anschaffung des
kampfjets f-35 der ja auch die nukleare
eile habe deutschlands sichern soll das
ist sicherlich ein punkt da werden sie
keine probleme haben also woher also die
kenntnis über die genauen zahlen haben
weiß ich nicht will ich auch nicht
bestätigen denn das sind tatsächlich
dokumente die noch nicht öffentlich sind
aber insgesamt ist es kein geheimnis
frau becker hat das ja auch gerade
gesagt natürlich gehört das thema
nukleare teilhabe und deren
aufrechterhaltung zu denen tatsächlich
beschaffungs projekten die schon lange
bekannt sind und die vermutlich eben
dann auch von dem sondervermögen mit
erfasst sind und das ist auch sehr
wichtig weil der tornado tatsächlich an
seine dienstzeit ende kommt und wenn wir
die nukleare teilhabe aufrechterhalten
wollen brauchen wir ein anderes
trägersystemen die f35 ist dafür
geeignet und wenn das sonderpaket
zusammen mit den grünen mit der spd und
der fdp auf den weg gebracht wird dann
ist das ein klares bekenntnis zur
nuklearen teilhabe verwendest der
probleme gibt bei der opposition in dem
fall der cdu csu ist das eigentlich gut
für die ampel fraktionen denn zumindest
bei der spd stehen ja auch nicht alle
hinter diesem 100 milliarden paket
jessica rosenthal viele linkere jusos
haben gesagt das können wir nicht
mittragen also das kabinett hat
ursprünglich an sehr guten vorschlag
vorgelegt dann haben wir mit der union
verhandelt sind der union auch
entgegengekommen ich fand den
ursprünglichen entwurf deutlich besser
weil dann auch die frage des schutts im
raum besser abgedeckt gewesen wäre durch
diese mittel und natürlich auch die
gefahr einfach da ist dass es zu einem
cyberangriff kommt aber insofern kann
ich wirklich nicht verstehen dass herr
hahn jetzt gerade sagt dass wir jetzt
vielleicht die verabschiedungen nicht
mehr in dieser woche machen sollen wir
sind der union entgegen gekommen die
haben da eigentlich schon eingeschlagen
und deshalb bin ich wirklich sehr
erstaunt über das chaos das heute morgen
herrscht wir sollten schnell entscheiden
aus staatspolitischer verantwortung muss
auch die union jetzt meine burschen
kommen heute abend wieder sitzung der
ausschüsse kann es also sein dass man
sich heute abend dann noch einig oder
würden sie sagen die stimmung ist diese
woche abgeblasen nein also das kann auf
jeden fall sein es ist auch noch mal wir
sind da auch absolut willens es geht
auch nicht darum tatsächlich dieses
wichtige projekt völlig mit dem
bundeskanzler einer meinung dass das
notwendig ist und das wollen wir auch
unterstützen überhaupt gar keine frage
da gibt es auch bei uns in der fraktion
überhaupt gar keinen keinen disput
darüber beziehungsweise keine abweichler
wir werden das sehr geschlossen dann
tatsächlich auf den weg bringen wenn es
soweit ist aber noch einmal 100
milliarden mal ein paar milliarden hier
oder da verschieben das geht so nicht
wir wollen hier klarheit haben und das
wollen wir im laufe des tages klären bis
zur sondersitzung des
verteidigungsausschusses im
haushaltsausschuss ist heute abend das
mit den milliarden dürfte politiker
nicht so schwer fallen sprechen seit der
griechenland krise sind wir es gewohnt
auch über 24 stunden plötzliche
entscheidungen zu treffen frau bürger
wenn wir mal die aufteilung angucken
dieser 100 milliarden da fällt auf wenn
sie mir das mal erklären können 20 7
milliarden für die führungsfähigkeit der
bundeswehr darin digitalisierung und
auch was mit forschung entwicklung gibt
es dann auch noch mit satelliten
kommunikation in der tat hat die
verteidigungsministerin jahr beklagt
dass sie gar nicht an satelliten denkt
sondern an normale funkgeräte denn bei
nato einsätzen ist es so dass deutsche
soldaten gar nicht mit diesem material
umgehen können also ist das hier schon
ein bisschen ein bisschen zukunftsmusik
die da beschrieben wird mit
krieg in den welten im weltraum nein es
ist keine zukunftsmusik sondern im
gegenteil aus den vergangenen jahren
auch natürlich in der verantwortung der
letzten bundesregierung gibt es
zahlreiche probleme der bundeswehr die
immer wieder verschleppt und verzögert
worden sind gerade im beschaffungs
bereich und das er braucht es jetzt
dieses sondervermögen einerseits
angesichts der extremen
sicherheitspolitischen lage die wir bei
den angriffskrieg in der ukraine haben
dass wir mehr für unseren schutz der
bürgerinnen und bürger aber auch unsere
verbündeten tun müssen und andererseits
diese ganzen probleme der letzten jahre
jetzt einmal solide und seriös
aufarbeiten müssen das kann ja nicht
sein dass die bundeswehr
nicht über verschlüsselten funk verfügt
und deshalb nato übungen so stattfinden
das ehrlich gesagt russland sie fast
eins zu eins ab die wehr beauftragt hat
vor kurzem ihren bericht vorgelegt und
hat gesagt 77
einsatzfähigkeit der hauptwaffensysteme
das ist reichlich wenig herr hahn wie
kommt das die union hat jahre lang
regiert warum ich die bundeswehr so
schlecht zurecht ja das ist vollkommen
richtig das ist nicht befriedigend und
am vor allem mit blick auf die aktuelle
krisensituation in europa ausgelöst
durch den krieg den mut ihn angezettelt
hat aber es liegt natürlich daran dass
wir in den letzten jahren zu wenig
investiert haben die union hätte das
gerne getan das ist am koalitionspartner
vor allem finanzminister scholz
tatsächlich gescheitert die spd hat
sogar wahlkämpfe bestritten wo sie
plakatiert hat die union möchte zwei
prozent erreichen wir möchten gerne die
kostenfreie kita so war die lage und
mitbringen kann ich nur sagen ich habe
die anträge zu den haushaltsberatungen
vergangenen jahren
verteidigungsausschuss habe ich die
anträge der grünen vermisst wo sie da
auch getränk hätten wir müssen mehr
investieren denn die bundeswehr sollte
sagen gutes stichwort der bundeskanzler
hat jetzt geht es dann angekündigt dass
man im ringtausch mit griechenland
panzer liefern wird es gibt ja schon in
slowenien polen diesen ringtausch bisher
hat noch überhaupt nicht stattgefunden
der bundestag hat entschieden schwere
waffen zu liefern bisher hat noch
überhaupt keine waffen liefern statt
davon was ist da los es ist ja nicht so
dass keine waffenlieferungen schwerer
waffen gerade in den ersten wochen es
glaube ich viel auch geliefert worden
was wirklich einen unterschied gemacht
hat und jetzt wird ja beispielsweise in
idar oberstein an der panzerhaubitze
ausgebildet damit dieses system wenn es
in die ukraine gebracht wird auch
schnell in den einsatz kommen kann
natürlich müssen wir uns jeden tag
fragen was wir tun können um die
waffenlieferung auch zu beschleunigen
und auszuweiten daran arbeiten wir in
der ampelkoalition nicht aber noch
einmal auf den hinweis von herrn hahn
sagen seit der annexion der krimis ja
der verteidigungshaushalt deutlich
angestiegen und das problem ist nicht
nur dass mangelnde geld gewesen sondern
dass man mit unseriösen wahlkreis
wünschen die nicht in
sicherheitspolitischen prioritäten
entsprochen haben unfassbar viel geld in
beschaffung skandalen verbrannt hat ja
und das muss jetzt christine lambrecht
lösen mit der gleichen beschaffungs
würde nämlich in koblenz fast 10.000
beamte sitzen da das scheint nicht zu
funktionieren ihre vorgängerinnen haben
sich ja auch da die zähne ausgebrochen
ausgebissen herr weise der ehemalige
chef der bundesanstalt für arbeit hat
gesagt wir müssen das ganze umbauen in
einer agentur wäre das eine gute idee
das würden wir gerne tun wir haben das
auch als union immer vorgeschlagen auch
das ist im übrigen am koalitionspartner
spd gescheitert einen letzten koalition
ich bin guter hoffnung frau lambrecht
hat sehr ambitionierte ziele ausgegeben
was die in der reform des
beschaffungsprozesses angeht wir werden
sehen wie die 100 milliarden dann auch
tatsächlich abfließen das ist sozusagen
daran wird er gemessen aber lassen sie
mich noch einen satz sagen zum thema
schwere waffen es gibt allein 150
kampfpanzer leopard 1 die tatsächlich
sofort verfügbar wären es gebe
vermutlich mehr als 100
schützenpanzer marder die sofort
verfügbar werden für die ukraine das
sind dinge die aktuell von der
bundesregierung blockiert werden ich
kann das bis heute nicht verstehen wir
könnten viel schneller tatsächlich
wirksame schwere waffen an die ukraine
gegeben und es liegt auch nicht an den
grünen robert habeck fordert das ja auch
immer anton hofreiter hat gerade gesagt
bis jetzt ist viel zu wenig passiert
homburger was ist da los können sie
zufrieden sein mit dem verhalten der
sozialdemokraten sage ich jetzt mal in
dem sinne mit dem bundeskanzler der
rücksicht nehmen muss oder treiber
rücksicht nimmt auf teile seiner
fraktion denn es passiert einfach viel
zu langsam etwas natürlich ist es
wichtig dass solche entscheidung auch
immer eine abwägung von risiken und
gefahren getroffen werden und ich finde
es erstmal nicht falsch dass eine
regierung sich solche entscheidungen
auch nicht einfach macht das modell ist
ja folgendes dass wir über den
ringtausch
sicherstellen dass verbündete die noch
gerät aus sowjet beständen haben das
schnell in die ukraine bringen können
dafür keine ausbildung erforderlich ist
und wir die anderen entscheidungen jetzt
auf den weg bringen müssen und eben
fragen von instandsetzungen munition
ausbildung auch mit klären müssen wie
das bei der panzerhaubitze geschehen ist
aber den ringtausch verstehe ich ehrlich
gesagt nicht weil es wird immer gesagt
die bundeswehr kann keine waffen abgeben
wenn man jetzt an griechenland panzer
liefert dann sind das jag panzer aus den
beständen der bundeswehr da wird immer
gesagt eigentlich geht dass sich die
können wir nicht in die ukraine liefern
da geht es nicht nur um die bedienung
sondern auch in der argumentation auch
darum wir sind sonst nicht für die
landesverteidigung aufgestellt diese
panzer werden nicht so schnell
nachgebaut werden können auch wenn man
die nach griechenland bringt also
irgendwie kommt die rechnung nicht hin
ja wobei es gibt einerseits beständen
der bundeswehr und bestände bei der
industrie die teilweise noch
modernisiert werden müssen das muss man
auch auseinanderhalten und in beiden
fällen gibt es potenziale bei der
industrie sicherlich deutlich größer als
bei der bundeswehr ich muss aber auch
sagen unsere freiheit unsere sicherheit
die wird gerade in der ukraine
verteidigt und das sollten wir auch
sehen wenn wir in die bestände der
bundeswehr schauen und da sehr
pragmatisch entscheiden was wir jetzt
abgeben können um schnell zu helfen kann
die linke argumentiert immer es war usus
dass man nicht in kriegsgebiete waffen
liefert es scheint hier so einen
gemeinsamen konsens zu geben dass eben
die ukraine auf unsere freiheit
verteidigt und wir natürlich alle
möglichst alle waffen liefern sollten
ist das eigentlich der richtige weg hat
die linke einen punkt gefunden der
jahrelange deutsche außenpolitik geprägt
hat ich habe die linke die irrlichtert
tatsächlich auch bei diesem thema gibt
es auch ganz unterschiedliche stimmen
gibt auch linke die tatsächlich
inzwischen die waffenlieferungen
befürworten beispielsweise der ehemalige
außenpolitische sprecher liebig der das
ganz klar befürwortet hier wird aber
klar das dilemma so und eins ist richtig
es ist so die ukraine schützt auch
unsere freiheit im moment und verteidigt
auch unsere freiheit und deswegen ist es
ein wichtiges anliegen dass die ukraine
unterstützt wird und dass russland nicht
gewinnt weil eins ist auch klar wenn
russland gewinnt dann wird sich russland
überlegen was der nächste schritt ist
aber das rumgeeiere dabei der geschichte
weil er bei den europäern das wird sich
ja wiederholen beim gas und deutschland
sind ganz vorne denn wir sind total
abhängig insofern kann man den ungarn ja
auch ein bisschen verstehen ist völlig
abhängig von diesen öllieferungen also
noch mal machen wir eigentlich genug von
dem was die ukraine dringend bräuchte
wenn man der meinung ist man muss der
ukraine helfen die bundesregierung
arbeitet jeden tag daran und zwar von
der frage der sanktionen bis hin zur
frage der waffenlieferung dinge auf den
weg zu bringen und zu beschleunigen
natürlich ist es ein problem dass wir
uns in den letzten jahren die
vergangenen bundesregierung sich so
blauäugig abhängig gemacht haben von
einem autokraten wie wladimir putin es
ist nicht einfach da jetzt schon
herauszukommen das geht bei kohle und öl
deutlich einfacher als beim gas aber
daran arbeitet robert habe grund
ungeboren ja und jetzt geht es gleich
los das wird sicherlich eine muntere
debatte frau bürger heran vielen dank
heute abend nochmal
verteidigungsausschuss mal sehen was
dann hier am freitag abgestimmt wird
oder ob überhaupt abgestimmt wird über
das sondervermögen aber es gibt ja noch
viele viele andere politische felder ich
glaube nur dass dieses sondervermögen
auch eine wichtige rolle in der debatte
spielt die sicherlich gleich friedrich
merz eröffnet wird ich gehe jetzt rein
ins plenum
sehr geehrte damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ich wünsche
einen schönen guten morgen die sitzung
ist eröffnet
wir setzen die haushaltsberatungen fort
ich rufe auf den einzelplan 4
für das bund für den bundeskanzler und
das bundeskanzleramt mit den
beschlussempfehlungen des
haushaltsausschusses auf drucksachen
1604 und
1626 berichterstattungen haben die
abgeordneten otto fricke dennis rohde
kerstin radomski
andreas dresch markus buhl und dr gesine
lötzsch sowie den einzelplan 22 für den
unabhängigen kontrollrat mit den
beschlussempfehlungen des
haushaltsausschusses auf der drucksache
berichterstattung haben die abgeordneten
dr andré berghegger martin gerster sven
christian kindler torsten herbst
wolfgang wehle und dr gesine lötzsch
über den einzelplan 04 werden wir später
namentlich abstimmen für die aussprache
wurde eine dauer von 210 minuten
vereinbart ich eröffne hiermit die
aussprache und als erster hat das wort
für die cdu/csu-fraktion friedrich merz
brauche ich meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen am vergangenen sonntagabend
konnten wir uns mit den
koalitionsfraktionen auch die
einzelheiten einer grundgesetzänderung
zur errichtung eines sonderfonds
verständigen mit dem die ausrüstung und
die ausrüstung der bundeswehr
zusätzlich mit 100 milliarden euro
ausgestattet werden dieser sonntag war
müssen zuallererst ein guter tag für die
bündnisse und verteidigungsfähigkeit des
landes im western guter tag für die
bundeswehr
ich will an dieser stelle herzlich dank
sagen an diejenigen die auf unserer
seite der cdu csu bundestagsfraktion
die gespräche mit den
koalitionsfraktionen geführt haben
unsere kollegen alexander dobrindt
mathias middelberg zur wadephul und
florian hahn herzlichen dank dafür dass
sie die verhandlungen zielorientiert und
konstruktiv in unser aller namen geführt
haben
ebenfalls ein dank sagen an die
koalitionsfraktionen
dass sie bereit waren unseren wünschen
vollumfänglich zu folgen fast die
ausgestaltung dieses sondervermögen
naja also wenn sie sie sind unseren
wünschen vollumfänglich nachgekommen und
ich will das noch mal kurz referieren
die 100 milliarden werden nur für die
bundeswehr zur verfügung gestellt es
wird einen wirtschaftsplan geben in dem
alle vorhaben aufgelistet werden die
die bundeswehr wird erstmalig in ihrer
geschichte einen
finanzierungsgesetz bekommen indem
klargestellt wird dass deutschland auch
nach der erschöpfung dieser 100
milliarden euro alle verpflichtungen
gegenüber der nato auch in zukunft
einhalten wird und das können auch mehr
als zwei prozent des
bruttoinlandproduktes sein meine damen
und herren das ein guter vorschlag
gewesen
es wird darüber hinaus bis zur
sommerpause und der bundeskanzler da
sehen wir sie in der pflicht das
wirklich auch einzuhalten was ihre
verhandlungsführer zugesagt haben einen
vorschlag zur reform des
beschaffungswesens geben den sehen wir
als notwendig und als dringlich an es
wird schließlich eine beteiligung des
haushaltsausschusses mit einem
unterausschuss geben an der einzelnen
finanzierung und es wird abschließend
der bundesfinanzminister einen
tilgungsplan geben den sie ebenfalls
zugesagt habe besser hätten wir es nicht
zu einem abschluss gemeinsam bringen
können herzlichen dank nochmal auch an
ihre adresse weinberg
nur hätten wir uns gewünscht dass auch
im hinblick auf die unmittelbare
herausforderung
der wir in diesen tagen und wochen
gestellt sind nämlich der eindämmung des
krieges in der ukraine
ähnlich klare und eindeutige politische
entscheidungen in deutschland
getroffen worden wären werden zu allen
gewünscht meine damen und herren dass
die bundesregierung dem wunsch und dem
auftrag des deutschen bundestages
nachgekommen wäre den wir wenn auch herr
bundeskanzler in ihrer abwesenheit am 28
april ebenfalls in großer
übereinstimmung wie im deutschen
bundestag in einem entschließungsantrag
formuliert haben wir haben zur
erinnerung unter anderem beschlossen
neben der humanitären und finanziellen
hilfe der ukraine auch schwere waffen zu
liefern damit dieses land sich gegen die
russische aggression ausreichend und
erfolgreich verteidigen kann
so haben
muss ich feststellen mehr als einen
monat nach dieser gemeinsamen
entschließung im deutschen bundestag
sind der ukraine bis zum heutigen tag
die zugesagten waffen nicht geliefert
worden mehr als einen monat statt dessen
werden von mitgliedern ihrer
bundesregierung herr bundeskanzler und
aus ihrer partei heraus ständig
irgendwelche behauptungen aufgestellt
die schlicht und einfach falsch sind so
wird von einer parlamentarischen
staatssekretärin aus dem
bundesverteidigungsministerium behauptet
es gebe da eine nato vereinbarung dass
es keine schweren waffen
gelte für die programme ihre
parteivorsitzende der bundeskanzler sagt
auch andere länder würden keine schweren
waffen liefern sei zwar keine formale
vereinbarung aber so eine art informelle
vereinbarung dass diese waffen nicht
geliefert und sie herr bundeskanzler
reden in letzter zeit etwas mehr als
sonst aber sie sagen unverändert nichts
was uns eine meinung zu dem was dieser
koalition
werthmann sich um unter den staats und
regierungschefs den abgeordneten in der
europäischen union dann kann ich
feststellen über die haltung der
bundesregierung gibt es mittlerweile nur
noch verstimmungen vorsichtig formuliert
es gibt enttäuschungen über die unklare
rolle deutschlands und es gibt richtig
verärgerung über sie und ihre regierung
und nicht nur während die opposition
sondern abgeordnete aus ihren reihen
seien bundeskanzler machen ihrem ärger
und ihrem unmut über das was sie in den
letzten tagen und wochen geschieht immer
lauter luft bis hin zu der wortmeldung
einer europaabgeordneten der kollegin
viola von cramon von den grünen die in
der letzten woche gesagt hat sie
brüsteten sich damit was man bereits für
die ukraine schon alles geleistet habe
sie würden dabei auf absprachen
verweisen mit vermeintlichen partnern
die es überhaupt nicht gebe ohne die
hilfe der usa sei die ukraine längst von
russland überrollt worden
abschließendes zitat für deutschland
bleibt jetzt nur noch verachtung übrig
ja das ist nicht aus unseren reihen und
bundesweiter das kommt aus ihren reihen
aus den reihen ihrer terrorliste
und am montag dieser woche titelte die
faz
scholz ruiniert das ansehen der
deutschen politik
wörtliches zitat im text olaf scholz hat
immer wieder auf seinen amtseid
hingewiesen schaden vom deutschen volk
abzuwenden
den schaden den er gerade in nicht
abwendet liegt im ansehensverlust der
deutschen politik
reflektion und vorsicht so schreibt
einer der herausgeber der faz
reflexion um vorsicht gelten nicht ohne
grund als tugenden sie als fassade für
zaudern zu verwenden ist unredlich
unredlich so eine auszeichnung durch
eine große deutsche tageszeitung muss
man sich erstmal verdienen
unredlich steht als synonym für
böswillig verschweigen tunn aufrichtig
und ehrlich wer meine damen und herren
was verschweigen sie uns eigentlich herr
bundeskanzler
sie telefonieren 80 minuten mit dem
krieg mit dem russischen
staatspräsidenten
und morgen kommt der
parlamentspräsident der ukraine nach
deutschland nach berlin und sie
verweigern ihm bis zu dieser minute
einen gesprächstermin
herr bundeskanzler was ist da eigentlich
los in ihrer regierung ich kann begrenzt
verstehen dass sie nicht nach kiew
reisen wollen aber wenn der
parlamentspräsident der zweithöchste
repräsentant der ukraine morgen in
berlin ist warum geben sie dem
parlamentspräsidenten der ukraine keinen
gesprächstermin was die stars
in deutschland
was heißt das wenn sie sagen russland
darf diesen krieg nicht gewinnen
das heißt das wenn sie sagen die ukraine
muss fortbestehen warum sagen sie nicht
einfach und ganz klar die ukraine muss
diesen krieg gewinnen
[Applaus]
warum sagen sie es nicht ganz klar
russland muss zumindest hinter die
kontakt linie vom 24 februar 2022
zurückgedrängt werden
jeden schritt auf der welt unten in
europa es sagen es ist auch nicht meine
oder unsere frage allein gibt es da
mittlerweile eine zweite agenda warum
widerspricht aus ihren reihen der spd
niemand ihrem amtsvorgänger im amt des
bürgermeisters der freien und hansestadt
hamburg klaus von dohnanyi der hier in
diesen tagen durch berlin von einer
talkshow in die andere geht russland in
schutz nimmt putin verteidigt und fast
ausschließlich den vereinigten staaten
von amerika die schuld an diesem krieg
zu weiß herr bundeskanzler was machen
sie da und warum stellen sie das nicht
klar was sie für eine meinung zu diesem
thema
sie haben am 27 februar von dieser
stelle aus eine vielbeachtete
regierungserklärung abgegeben sie haben
hier im deutschen bundestag sehr viel
zustimmung bekommen
stehenden applaus auch von meiner
fraktion
ja das haben wir wohl zur kenntnis
genommen haben meine damen und herren
aber sie bleiben doch hinter den selbst
gestellten ansprüchen dieses 27 februar
mittlerweile tag für tag immer weiter
zurück sie haben an diesem tag klartext
gesprochen
sie haben an diesem tag ist sagt sie die
lage sehen seitdem verdampft und
verdunstet das alles was sie da gesagt
haben im unklaren im ungefähren und es
wird keine konkrete entscheidung hier
getroffen und hier begründet die an
dieses niveau und in diesem level
anschließen sie am 27 februar 2022 ihr
selbst gesetzt hat
mit einem zweiten aspekt hinzu fügen wir
sind ja nicht allein auf dieser welt
aber warum gibt es eigentlich warum gibt
es eigentlich von ihrer regierung der
bundeskanzler auch von ihnen persönlich
keine einzige europäische initiative zum
beispiel zusammen mit dem französischen
staatspräsidenten wie man in einer
solchen historischen situation jetzt
europa voran bringt und mit anderen
mitgliedstaaten zusammen auch in der
europäischen politik klar zeigt in
welche richtung jetzt europa entwickelt
werden soll und welche chancen europa
auch in diesem konflikt sieht für die
eigene bessere integration in der außen-
sicherheits- und verteidigungspolitik
ich würde es mal so sagen haben sie
eigentlich außer der
formalen rhetorik irgendeinen vorschlag
wie sich europa in dieser historischen
phase des umbruchs aufstellen und
dauerhaft auch verteidigen kann gibt es
irgendeinen vorschlag aus ihrer
regierung
sehen sie wenn sie wenigstens teile des
geldes das wir jetzt in diesem
sondervermögen bereitstellen wollen in
eine europäische sicherheitsarchitektur
ein die es uns erlaubt schritt für
schritt hin zu einer europäischen außen-
sicherheits- und verteidigungspolitik zu
kommen und in diesem zusammenhang wie
wird eigentlich die bundesregierung wie
werden sie herr bundeskanzler votieren
wenn in wenigen tagen der neuesten
nächste europäische rat stattfindet und
auf der tagesordnung steht die frage ob
der ukraine moldau und ob den
westbalkanstaaten der beitritt status
der kandidatenstatus in die europäische
union gegeben wird herr bundeskanzler
das können sie doch nicht der eu
kommission überlassen das irgendwie
formal vorzubereiten das ist doch eine
zutiefst politische entscheidung in der
hauptschule in der
erwartet
williams offen lassen wenn die größte
nation der europäischen union in dieser
frage unklar bleibt und keine klare
antwort gibt dann bleibt es in ganz
europa und klar und dann wird es in ganz
europa keine antwort geben also bitte
sagen sie was sie von dieser frage
halten und wie sie das sehen die
westbalkanstaaten moldau und die ukraine
sollen sie den kandidaten status
bekommen oder nicht
oder aber setzen sie das ford mit ihrer
politik was sie als finanzminister schon
in den letzten jahren ihrer regierung
getan haben nämlich praktisch jedes geld
jedes problem einfach nur mit neuem geld
zuzuschütten und ansonsten politischen
entscheidungen aus dem wege zu gehen
ich will noch mal auf in dem
zusammenhang mit dem bundeshaushalt 2022
stellen sind ihnen eigentlich die
risiken bewusst mit denen sie diesen
bundeshaushalt in dieser woche hier
verabschiedet und zwar auf ganz
unabhängig von den neuen schulden die
jetzt mit diesem sondervermögen gemacht
werden es könnte doch sein der
bundeskanzler dass sie schon in wenigen
wochen 60 milliarden euro für den klima-
und energiefonds gar nicht zur verfügung
haben weil ihnen das
bundesverfassungsgericht nicht erlaubt
diese mittel aus den kommunen helfen
aus dem corona hilfen zweck zu
entfremden für die entscheidungen ihrer
regierung die eigentlich aus dem
normalen haushalt finanziert werden
müssten
das könnte sein es könnte sein dass sie
jahr für jahr zehn milliarden euro
zurückzahlen müssen an diejenigen die
einkommensteuer und körperschaftsteuer
zahlen weil es an ihnen gescheitert ist
den solidaritätszuschlag in der letzten
wahlperiode vollständig abzuschaffen das
ist ein jährlich fließen
in zusammenhang wenn sie dann als nicht
aus ideologischen gründen sich geweigert
hätten den soli ganz abzuschaffen sie
hätten heute mit diesem instrument das
sie selbst diskreditiert haben sie
hätten heute mit diesem instrument ein
instrument zur verfügung mit dem wir
wahrscheinlich die neuen schulden für
das sondervermögen bundeswehr gar nicht
hätten aufnehmen müssen sie hätten uns
nämlich den vorschlag machen können der
bundeskanzler dass wir einen solchen
solidaritäts zuschlag erheben auf die
einkommensteuer und auf die
körperschaftssteuer für die bundeswehr
dann wäre das vom heutigen generationen
bezahlt worden was eigentlich aufgabe
der heutigen generation nicht und nicht
die junge redaktion
jahren hatte den mühsamen
abzahlen und in dem zusammenhang was
sagen sie eigentlich der jungen
generation was sagen ja dass dabei
irgendwo bei ihnen auch kommt das kann
ich gut verstehen meine damen und herren
bei
[Musik]
dem optionen glänzen ihre augen nicht
das hätten sie gerne aber sie können ihn
nicht einführen weil sie dieses
instrument einfach mutwillig zerstört
was sagen sie eigentlich der
bundeskanzler der jungen generation dass
sie es erneut versuchen wird auch mit
diesem bundeshaushalt eine reform
was sagen sie eigentlich der jugend
generation
[Musik]
was sagen sie eigentlich der integration
dass sie es erneut versäumt
eine reform der rentenversicherung
vorzulegen die einerseits den
bundeszuschuss begrenzt und andererseits
der jungen generation eine sichere
altersversorgung ermöglicht auch hier
eine zahl die steuern
ja es gibt ich kann das ist kann das gut
verstehen
das ist nicht nur da sondern auch da auf
der regierungsbank gehörige unruhe gibt
sie müssen sie müssen sie müssen mehr
als 100 milliarden euro pro jahr an
zuschuss in die rentenversicherung
zahlen es gibt bis heute kein vorschlag
aus der koalition diese
rentenversicherung zu reformieren der
letzte reformvorschlag ist an ihnen
gescheitert und an ihnen herr
bundeskanzler in der letzten koalition
wir hätten
der reform machen müssen die ist an
ihnen gescheitert sie haben ihre
zustimmung verweigert zum gegen
reformvorschlag der gemacht worden ist
und so bleibt heute festzustellen das
wort zeitenwende dass sie am 27 februar
2022 geprägt und verwendet haben dieses
wort zeitenwende bleibt außer neuen
schulden für dieses sondervermögen mehr
oder weniger beziehungslos im raum
stehen es gibt nichts was sie außer
neuen schulden mit diesem wort zeigten
verwende zeitenwende ernst
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wird schön bleiben wie sie es in ihrem
koalitionsvertrag der mittlerweile nur
noch ins archiv gehört wie sie in ihrem
koalitionsvertrag verabredet haben im
gegenteil aus ihren reihen kommen fast
im wochenrhythmus neue vorschläge wie
man zusätzliches geld ausgibt der
jüngste vorschlag ihres sozialministers
ein soziales klima geld für einkommen
bis 8000 euro im monat
schauen sie sich mal die reihen dieser
koalition haben bei diesem wort soziales
klima geht welche reaktionen dass hier
im hause aus
das ist schon ganz interessant sind
einfach platt und linkspartei noch ein
bisschen zeit hat aber ansonsten
visionär für dieses thema sie machen
solche vorschläge hier und ohne jede
finanzierung einfach zusätzliche neue
schulden das ist die botschaft dieser
regierung ist ganz nah ich möchte in
einen vorschlag machen zum abschluss
meiner rede sie haben vermutlich eine
vorformulierte ausformulierte rede des
bundeskanzleramtes mitgebracht heute
morgen legen sie doch mal auf die seite
und beantworten sie bitte wenn es eben
möglich ist drei sehr konkrete fragen
die erste frage ist welche waffen
liefert die bundesrepublik deutschland
wirklich an die ukraine welche waffen
wollen und sie liefern was ist ihre
präzise antwort auf diese war zweitens
zweiter
der bundeskanzler wie werden sie
europäischen rat abstimmen wenn die
frage beantwortet werden muss gibt es
für die ukraine und andere staaten den
beitritt status den kandidatenstatus in
die europäische union und dritte frage
und auch die auch die politik ist heute
morgen abweichend vom vorgetragenen
vorgelesenen redemanuskript ihr zu
beantworten welche vorschläge machen sie
zur reform der deutschen
rentenversicherung damit die junge
generation in diesem land eine
perspektive auch an der gesicherten
alters was ich singe anstifter in einer
debatte über digitales können sie ganz
dass diese fragen beantworten
friedrich merz der
oppositionsführer hier mit seiner rede
er hat gesagt
dass die 100 milliarden und die
zeitenwende nichts weitergebracht haben
nach drei monaten als neue schulden sie
herr bundeskanzler reden um letzter zeit
mehr als sonst aber sie sagen nichts
fertiges vorgeworfen was heißt das eben
keine muss fortbestehen sagen sie doch
mal wie sie sich das vorstellen warum
sagen sie nicht dass die ukraine
gewinnen muss er hat kritisiert dass der
karnische präsident der natürlich von
der deutschen parlamentspräsidenten
heute empfangen würden nicht mehr
bundeskanzler empfangen wird und scholz
lasse es an führung vermissen was zum
beispiel die innenperspektive für die
ukraine westbalkanstaaten moldau und
keine angeht hat man vom deutschen
bundeskanzler auch noch nie ein klares
wort hört am ende seiner rede hat er
aufgefordert diese fragen zu beantworten
und jetzt der bundestag
werter herr merz sie haben sich mit dem
text den sie sich vorbereitet haben wir
ein manuskript ja sehr viel mühe gegeben
allerdings muss man ausdrücklich sagen
das was sie hier vorgetragen hat sind
lauter fragen sie sind hier durch die
sache durch die tänze und haben nichts
konkretes gesagt morbid wäre wirklich
sehr vernünftig gewesen
wenn sie nicht mit durchkommen immer nur
fragen zu stellen und sich niemals in
irgendeiner frage sinnvoll zu
positionieren und wenn sie es dann
machen dann wird's peinlich also 7
sie kritisieren her dass ich mit dem
russischen präsidenten telefoniere und
sie kritisieren hier das sich mit dem
russischen präsidenten liegt ihre von
mehreren inseln wären das dann sagen sie
ich soll was gemeinsames mit dem
französischen präsident machen und
während sie in ihrer rede dass inseriert
haben haben sie völlig übersehen das
letzte telefongespräch war ein
gemeinsames mit dem französischen
präsidenten übrigens eine europäische
aktion dieser beiden länder die eine
wichtige rolle für die zukunft europas
spielen
und ganz anders als sie das hier
herstellen sind die anderen länder
europas überwiegend sehr sehr froh
darüber dass wir genau das machen und
freuen sich darüber dass wir mit ihnen
unsere erkenntnisse austauschen dass wir
darüber reden was gemeinsam vorzutragen
ist und was wir tun wollen naja und dann
hatten sie ja noch einen konkreten
vorschlag den muss man sich ja doch noch
mal auf der zunge zergehen lassen ihr
vorschlag den sie heute hier im
deutschen bundestag gemacht haben ist
dass wir die steuern für fast alle
bürgerinnen bürger über ein soli erhöhen
sollen um die bessere ausrüstung der
bundeswehr zu bezahlen was für ein
merkwürdiger einfallen
einen ganzen bundestagswahlkampf haben
sie damit geführt zu sagen dass der soli
auch für die leute die 200 300 400
tausend euro im jahr verdienen weg muss
um dann jetzt vorzuschlagen dass leute
die 70.000 60.000 euro verdient den soli
jetzt aber zahlen sollen damit das jetzt
hier gemacht werden können das ist keine
gute idee
und wer ihre fragen beantworten oder sie
sind alle längst beantwortet bei den
gelegenheiten dazu da waren aber ich
will ausdrücklich dazu sagen eins ist
schon ganz ganz zentral wenn man über
das redet was wir reden auch wenn es um
die verbesserung unserer
verteidigungsanstrengungen geht dann
muss man als oppositionsführer der von
der cdu csu kommt schon sagen die
verteidigungsministerin und minister der
letzten jahre waren in der cdu und der
csu die kanzlerin weil der cdu und
darüber hätten sie auch noch wenig sein
wort verlieren
die schlechte zeit für die bundeswehr
hat begonnen als ein presse china viel
kommunizieren da selten sich in seinem
land aufhalten
bundesverteidigungsminister guttenberg
entschieden hat alles mögliche anders zu
machen ordentlich einzusparen die
wehrpflicht abzuschaffen und darunter
leiden wir noch heute dass all das geld
damals die gesamte strecke brauchen
manchmal ist sacharbeit wirklich eine
nützliche sache ernst
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
die preise für benzin und diesel für
lebensmittel und zurzeit sind steigen
rasant und millionen bürgerinnen und
bürger fragen sich jeden tag komme ich
ihn mit meinem geld reicht es noch am
monatsende
das sind sehr sehr sehr gravierende
fragen fragen auf die es in der tat eine
klare antwort braucht die
bundesregierung hat umfangreiche
entlastung von bürgern und bürger und
unternehmen auf den weg gebracht in der
summe reden wir über mehr als 30
milliarden euro
und diese entlastungen kommen jetzt an
in den nächsten tagen und wochen
rückwirkend ab januar wird die
pendlerpauschale erhöht um die hohen
spritpreise etwas auszugleichen ab
ersten juli werden die stromrechnung
günstiger weil wir die eeg-umlage
streichen eine vierköpfige familie spart
zu mehrere hundert euro im jahr und ab
juli bekommen bürgerinnen bürger mit
kleinen einkommen wohngeldempfänger
rinnen und studierende mit bafög ein
zuschuss zu den heizkosten
familien werden gezielt entlastet durch
den kinderbonus von armut betroffene
kinder und jugendliche erhalten sofort
zuschlag und zwar monatlich jeder
beschäftigte erhält ab september zum
ausgleich für die gestiegenen
energiekosten einmalig 300 euro
ausgezahlt und schon heute treten zwei
maßnahmen kraft über die wohl am meisten
geredet worden es in deutschland in den
vergangenen wochen die steuersenkung auf
benzin und diesel und das neun euro
ticket im öpnv
hier lastet damit diejenigen die nicht
aufs auto verzichten können und all
diejenigen die täglich bus und bahn
nutzen und vielleicht gewinnen wir auch
die eine oder andere in den anderen
dafür künftig etwas häufiger die
öffentlichen verkehrsmittel zu nutzen
jedenfalls ist der ansturm auf das neue
euro ticket ganz massiv und es zeigt die
maßnahmen wirken sie kommen direkt bei
den bürgerinnen und bürgern an und das
hat diese bundesregierung und die
regierungsmehrheit im bundestag auf den
rechner
weil die öffentlichkeit
ihre eigenen themen hat die diskutieren
der die scheiben der öffentlichkeit ist
es so dass das vielleicht noch nicht so
präsent geworden ist aber wenn das geld
denn jetzt gezahlt wird dann hoffe ich
wird den bürgern und bürgern die diese
hilfe wirklich dringend brauchen auch
sichtbar es kommt und das haben wir
gemacht übrigens profitieren auch die
renten und rentner von den entlastungs
paketen bei den stromrechnung vom tank
rabatt und dem neuen euro ticket und zum
ersten juli steigen die renten so stark
wie seit jahrzehnten nicht um 6,1
prozent 12 prozent im osten und über
5,35 im westen für drei millionen
rentnern rentner haben wir höhere
erwerbsminderungsrenten auf den weg
gebracht und wir werden das rentenniveau
bei 48 prozent stabilisieren damit es
nicht nach 2025 unterschritten wird das
ist eine wichtige leistung dieser region
wer sein leben lang gearbeitet und
beiträge gezahlt hat der muss sich auf
seine oder ihre rente verlassen können
das ist ein kernversprechen des
sozialstaates und wir werden das
erneuern
und in diesen zeiten große veränderungen
stattfinden da ist es umso wichtiger
dass sich alle verlassen können auf
sicherheit und zusammenhalt wir
entlasten übrigens auch die unternehmen
vor allem diejenigen die jetzt mit dem
krieg und den hohen energiekosten zu
kämpfen haben und haben ein schutzschild
errichtet und betreibt das betrieben bei
bedarf mit zuschüssen bürgschaft nur der
günstigen krediten unter die arme zu
greifen
mit dem ähnlichen instrumenten haben wir
es geschafft durch die korona pandemie
zu kommen und es ist gelungen
arbeitsplätze zu erhalten das ist eine
gute botschaft vor allem wenn wir jetzt
sagen können die beschäftigung es
gegenwärtig höher als vor der pandemie
es zeigt wenn ein land zusammenhält dann
kann man auch durch schwere krisen
kommen und diesen weg werden wir weiter
verfolgen
aber ich sage ganz offen
natürlich ist damit das problem
steigender preise noch nicht gelöst
denn der preisanstieg hat eine ganze
reihe von ursachen
ganz vorn der von russland angezettelten
krieg
was machen sie der von russland
angezettelten krieg
er heizt die energie und rohstoffpreise
an die internationalen lieferketten sind
oft noch die pandemie gestört
insbesondere in asien man sollte sich
nur einmal die vorstellung
vergegenwärtigen von den vielen schiffen
in den container hilfen chinas
insbesondere in shanghai und natürlich
haben die milliardenschweren
konjunkturpakete die viele länder nicht
nur wir aufgelegt haben dazu geführt
dass es eine höhere nachfrage gibt zum
beispiel nach rohstoffen
noch sind also diese preissteigerung
wahrscheinlich auf solche einmaligen
shops zurückzuführen aber wir müssen
aufpassen
aber wir müssen aufpassen dass daraus
keine dauerhafte entwicklung mit zu
hohen inflationsrate bei allem was wir
heute und auch künftig tun ist eins klar
kreditfinanzierte dauersubventionen sind
keine lösung zumal wir nächstes jahr die
verfassungsmäßig vorgeschriebenen
schuldenbremse wieder beachtet werden
ziel muss also sein den inflationsdruck
nachhaltig zu mildern und zugleich
behalten wir weiterhin die finanzielle
lage von rentnern rentnern von
grundsicherungsempfänger von
studentinnen und studenten und familien
genau im blick auch die arbeitnehmern
und arbeitnehmer fragen sich was sie
sich noch werden leisten können
die tarifpartner in der chemieindustrie
haben kürzlich einen sehr interessanten
weg gewählt
beschlossen wurden gestiegene preise
schnell und substanziell auszugleichen
über eine einmalige sonderzahlung auch
in der stahlindustrie wird darüber
gerade diskutiert auch in anderen
tarifen zum beispiel passieren haben
einmalige zahlung haben zahlung eine
rolle gespielt
die gute idee dahinter ist den
arbeitnehmern und arbeitnehmern
finanziell luft zu verschaffen ohne die
arbeitgeber zu überfordern und
inflationsrisiken anzuheizen
ich habe mich deshalb zusammen mit allen
verantwortlichen der regierung zu einem
ungewöhnlichen schritt entschlossen ich
möchte die arbeitnehmer- und
arbeitnehmer ihre gewerkschaften und die
arbeitgeber zu einer konzertierten
aktion zusammenrufen
das hat schon einmal geholfen dass wir
zusammen gestanden haben gewerkschaften
arbeitgeber staat auch viele andere die
verantwortung in diesem land haben um
mit einer schwierigen herausforderung
umzugehen und ich finde es ist richtig
wenn instrumente der zusammenarbeit und
des zusammenhalts von unternehmen von
beschäftigten von gewerkschaften
unternehmerverbänden von start von
kommunen von allen institutionen schon
einmal in schwierigen laden geholfen
haben zu sagen hier muss erneut
zusammengestanden werden und
herausgefunden werden wie wollen wir mit
dieser preisentwicklung umgehend ich bin
dazu bereit dass wir uns so
zusammentreffen
natürlich wird das keine aktivität sein
wo wir uns treffen und mal reden da wird
ganz konkret gesprochen und ich will
auch sagen alle werden etwas beitragen
müssen die sozialpartner die arbeitgeber
selbstverständlich denn sie haben eine
große verantwortung dafür dass die
finanzkraft ihrer beschäftigten groß
genug ist aber auch wir als gemeinschaft
und der staat und deshalb ist es eben
umso wichtiger dass wir das miteinander
machen wir brauchen eine gezielte
krankheit kraftanstrengung in einer ganz
außergewöhnlichen situation und wir sind
dazu bereit wir wollen eine konzertierte
aktion gegen den preisdruck
das ist natürlich keine lohn
verhandlungsrunde das machen die
tarifpartner aber es geht da um das
miteinander zu besprechen und ich weiß
aus den gesprächen mit den
verantwortlichen im gewerkschaften und
arbeitgeberverbänden und
unternehmensverbänden dass sie das sehr
begrüßen wenn wir genau das jetzt machen
die korona pandemie hat uns gezeigt wie
wichtig gesellschaftlicher zusammenhalt
ist ich wünsche mir dass wir das
bewahren die aktuelle infektions lage
verschafft uns zeit zum handeln benutzen
sie intensiv um uns und unser
gesundheitssystem gut auf herbst und
winter vorzubereiten und sie stellen
unser gesundheitssystem so auf dass es
zukunftssicher ist dazu gehört die
gesetzliche krankenversicherung
verlässlich zu finanzieren
darauf können sich die patienten und
patienten aber auch die beschäftigten im
gesundheitswesen verlassen die in den
vergangenen zweieinhalb jahren so
unglaublich viel geleistet hatten haben
für unser land und wir werden sie nicht
vergessen und sie weiter unterstützen
weil der zusammenhalt so wichtig ist
werden auch sozialreform weiter eine
rolle spielen es ist nicht so dass das
alles jetzt verschwindet hinter dem
krieg herr merz sondern es bleibt gerade
in dieser situation ganz ganz wichtig
dass wir etwas für den zusammenhalt tun
und deshalb werden wir die reformen
weiter voran bringen die wir uns als
regierung vorgenommen haben das
bürgergeld mit dem wir auf beratung
unterstützung setzen statt auf unnötige
bürokratie und und komplizierte
antragsverfahren und die
kindergrundsicherung die
unübersichtliche vielzahl
unterschiedlicher familienleistung
zusammenführen und verbessern soll alles
beides wird weiter vorangebracht
kinder und jugendliche die in armut
aufwachsen darf es an einem so reichen
land wie deutschland nicht geben das ist
ein grundsatz der für diese regierung
unabdingbar io e te
und selbstverständlich gehört dazu auch
dass wir jetzt
voran bringen was wir uns letztes jahr
vorgenommen haben
nämlich dass diejenigen die am wenigsten
verdienen einen besseren lohn bekommen
der mindestlohn wird ab oktober auf
zwölf euro in der stunde steigen es war
ein langer kampf jetzt wird das realität
das versprechen ist umgesetzt
wir wissen alle dass zwölf euro in der
stunde keine großen sprünge erlauben
aber es ist eine erleichterung für viele
die sehr sehr wenig geld haben gerade
wenn jetzt die preise steigen und es
macht einen unterschied für sechs
millionen bürgern und bürger was für
eine aussage über unser land und was ihr
verdient wird aber wie dringlich ist
diese reform gut dass jetzt kommt
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen faire
löhne sind das eine aber viele bürger
machen bürger stellen sich
grundsätzlichere fragen wie sicher ist
der arbeitsplatz wenn energie teurer
wird und lieferketten und sicherer wie
geht es weiter mit dem industrieland
deutschland
ich kann das gut verstehen und wir
wissen alle dass wir vor einer zweiten
industriellen revolution stehen nur ein
beispiel um in zukunft mit sauberen
strom betrieben zu werden braucht ein
chemie standort ludwigshafen mit basf in
etwa die strommenge von acht bis neun
windparks auf see
das klingt viel und das ist es auch
die gute nachricht ist schon vor den
kriegsbeginn in der ukraine hatte die
bundesregierung ein zukunftsplan um das
industrieland deutschland bis 2045 co2
neutral zu machen und dieser plan gilt
heute immer noch mehr als vorher
zwei dinge sind dafür entscheidend
erstens versorgungssicherheit energie
muss immer verfügbar sein 24 stunden am
tag 365 tage im jahr
die bundesregierung hat zuletzt
erhebliche fortschritte durchgesetzt um
unabhängig von russischen gast zu werden
schwimmen der flüssiggas terminals
werden kurzfristig bereit stehen mit
einem eigenen gesetz beschleunigen wir
den ausbau so dass in wenigen monaten
und nicht in jahren und jahrzehnten die
nötige infrastruktur errichtet wird
erschließen neue bezugsquellen
erst vorige woche habe ich dazu
gespräche in afrika geführt wir reden
auch mit norwegen mit kanada den usa und
katar
und terminals und leistung sondern
künftig auch für wasserstoff genutzt
werden denn darin liegt die zukunft
zweitens der ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien wird massiv beschleunigt
das oster paket ist bereits
verabschiedet zwei weitere pakete
folgenden sommer- und erz und wir wollen
die dauer der verwaltungsverfahren
mindestens halbieren und das
[Applaus]
stelle auch sehr klar sagen
wir werden uns nicht den schneid
abkaufen lassen meine damen und herren
nicht von den lobbyisten nicht von den
bedenkenträgern und auch nicht von den
verteidigern des status quo denn wenn
wir erst einmal anfangen dinge auf die
zeitschiene zu schieben dann werden wir
niemals rechtzeitig fertig werden es ist
zu lang wir haben die zeit dafür nicht
mehr dieses jahr ist das jahr der
entscheidung und entscheidung werden die
knochen
mit meinen kolleginnen und kollegen und
aus den niederlanden dänemark belgien
und den kommissionspräsidenten von
allein haben wir kürzlich die weichen
gestellt um aus nordseewind so etwas zu
machen wäre ein riesiges windenergie
kraftwerk das gleiche wollen wir für die
ostsee erreichen und die kommission hat
auch ihren beitrag geleistet mit dem
paket repower you das dazu beitragen
soll dass viele dinge schneller gehen
und den vielen fragen die jetzt von
einigen im vordergrund diskutiert werden
ist ja eine sache dabei ganz zentral es
soll noch einmal neue möglichkeiten der
beschleunigung beinhalten damit
verfahren einfacher werden und wird die
dinge besser voranbringen können auch
darüber haben wir bei der sondertagung
des europäischen rates gesprochen und es
bleibt ein ziel für ganz europa was für
uns unmittelbar geld wir wollen energie
unabhängigkeit erreichen so schnell wie
möglich das wissen wir ist diesen tagen
ganz ganz dringend angesichts des
russischen angriff
und wir wollen vollständige co2
neutralität bis 2045 erreichen das ist
machbar beides gehört zusammen es
schließt einander nicht aus und wir
werden beides erreichen
natürlich gehört dazu dass wir auch
jetzt die grundlagen dafür legen all das
voranzubringen was für unser land
wichtig ist bei forschungen innovation
bei digitalisierung wo wir mehr tempo
brauchen bei der aus und weiterbildung
und deshalb schaffen wir ein
qualifizierungs geld deshalb wollen wir
neue aufstiegsmöglichkeiten schaffen und
chancengerechtigkeit es schaffen eine
startchance programm wir bauen die
ganztagsbetreuung an schulen aus an
grundschulen die bafög-reform läuft und
wir wollen uns für eine
ausbildungsgarantie einsetzen damit
jugendlichen einen berufseinstieg nicht
verwehrt bleibt alles gast in tibet
zurück
denn wir brauchen die diese investition
in unsere zukunft wir brauchen die
besten der finderin die weltbesten
ingenieure und gut ausgebildete
facharbeiter rinnen und facharbeiter
ich habe eingangs über die erwartungen
der bürgerinnen und bürger gesprochen
und wir fragen und sorgen die wir in den
mittelpunkt unserer politik stellen und
die aktuell größte sorge ist ganz
unbedingt der furchtbaren krieg den
russland gegen die ukraine begonnen hat
uns alle schmerzen die schmerz die opfer
dieses verbrecherischen krieges der ihn
schon fast 100 tage wird mit jedem tag
steigen die opferzahlen
mit jedem tag werden mehr städte und
orte im trümmerwüste verwandelt
angesichts der russischen bomben und
artillerie und deshalb ist so wichtig
dass wir uns über das einig sind was wir
erreichen wollen putin darf und wird
diesen krieg nicht gewinnen
und es gibt jetzt eine situation in der
immer wieder darüber diskutiert wird was
die kriegsziele sind unsere unser ziel
ist dass putin nicht gewinnt unser ziel
ist dass die ukraine sich verteidigen
kann und damit erfolgreich ist aber ich
will ausdrücklich sagen ich will
ausdrücklich sagen es ist überheblich
und es ist unangemessen und es ist
völlig fehl am platze wenn hier zu lange
darüber diskutiert wird was die ukraine
richtigerweise zu entscheiden hat ich
sage es mit dem amerikanischen
präsidenten über die ukraine entscheiden
die ukraine ukraine und niemand sonst
man muss fielen genau zuhören was sie da
machen und dann höre ich viel was mir
nicht gefällt ich höre auf 4 aus anderen
den andern ländern was diskutiert wird
das will ich ausdrücklich sagen da gibt
es den einen oder anderen der vielleicht
auch denkt so könnte das noch gelingen
dann ist die sache endlich vorbei aber
das kann nicht sein wir werden die
ukraine ukraine so lange unterstützen
wie das erforderlich ist mit algen
möglichkeiten die wir auf den weg
gebracht haben
putin darf seine ziele nicht erreichen
er darf nicht mit seinem konzept
durchkommen mit einem brutalen
militärischen einsatz ein land zu
erobern oder teile davon das ist
imperialismus und den werden wir in
europa nicht akzeptieren
besser greifen unsere tiefgreifenden st
es sind übrigens die weitreichendsten
sanktionen die jemals gegen ein so
großes land weltweit verhängt worden
sind es sind sehr wirksame sanktionen
auch das muss dazu gesagt werden und
sitzt sanktionen mit dem putin niemals
gerechnet hat weil es sanktionen sind
die ausgeschlossenheit entstanden sind
und gerade dadurch ihre wirksamkeit
entfalten diese geschlossenheit müssen
wir bewahren
und was ist es gut
dass sich der europäische rat erst nach
dem 5 4 sanktionspaket die vorher
beschlossen waren auf ein sechstes
verständigt hat mit vielen weiteren sehr
detaillierten sanktionen an denen wir
lange gearbeitet haben und auch mit
einem ölembargo das dazugehört ich bin
froh dass diese entscheidung jetzt
getroffen worden ist
umsteigen zum herz aus der dem import
russischer kohle aus und für uns in
deutschland gilt trotz der ausnahme für
die pipeline anrainer wir werden
unverändert daran arbeiten bis zum
jahresende auch aus dem import von kohle
öl auszusteigen das bleibt unverändert
unser ziel
außerdem unterstützen wir die ukraine
finanziell mit sehr sehr viel mittel
gerade erst haben wir eine milliarde
zugesagt im rahmen der g7 eine direkte
zahlung aus deutschland die dazu
beitragen soll dass die ukraine dieser
situation herr werden kann der sie der
gefahr herr werden kann der sie
ausgesetzt ist und
neben der wirtschaftlichen und
finanziellen unterstützung
liefern wir auch waffen
eines will ich klarstellen
deutschland muss sich dann nicht
verstecken
wir liefern kontinuierlich von beginn
des krieges an
und unmittelbar nach kriegsbeginn haben
wir diese entscheidung getroffen und mit
einer langjährigen platz staatspraxis in
deutschland gebrochen es war eine
richtige entscheidung aber es war eine
mutige neue entscheidung dieser
regierung meine damen und herren
und weil sie hat nur fragen durch die
landschaft getänzelt sind herr merz noch
mal der hinweis
es ist eine regierung die von der cdu
geführt worden ist die diese
staatspraxis die letzten jahre hatte ich
will das nicht kritisieren aber so zu
tun als sei das nicht irgendein ganz
besonders weitreichender schritt gewesen
dass wir das jetzt gemacht haben das ist
nicht in ordnung und auch nichts an dem
film
eine zeitenwende
das ist der furchtbare imperialistische
angriff russlands auf sein nachbarland
das unschuldig überfallen worden ist
dass wir darauf reagieren
das sind weitreichende maßnahmen und zu
diesen beiden maßnahmen zählte schon als
allererstes dass wir diese staatspraxis
verändert haben ich verstehe nicht wie
dann immer wieder von ihm vorgetragen
würde es sei nichts passiert allein das
ist eine massive änderung der politik in
deutschland
wenige tage nach kriegsausbruch haben
wir flugabwehrraketen und
panzerabwehrwaffen geliefert also genau
das was zu dem zeitpunkt am dringendsten
nötig war dazu kommen bislang mehr als
15 millionen schuss munition
hunderttausend handgranaten über 5000
panzer abwärme umfangreiches
sprengmaterial
maschinengewehre dutzende lastwagen
ladung mit sonstigen relevanten gütern
zb zur drohen abwehr für mobilität
kommunikation und zur verpflegung und
versorgung verwundeter
gemeinsam mit dänemark haben wir der
ukraine auf ihren wunsch hin 54
modernisierte gepanzerte
truppentransporter geliefert über einen
ersten ringtausch mit unseren
tschechischen freunden bekommt die
ukraine vertrautes gerät britischer
bauart zunächst 20 kampfpanzer t 72 wir
sorgen für ersatz für tschechien weitere
gespräche laufen
erst gestern habe ich mit dem
griechischen ministerpräsidenten
mitsotakis verabredet dass griechenland
schützenpanzer aus ehemaligen informer
beständen liefern wird und wir dafür die
griechischen bestände mit deutschen
schützenpanzern auffüllen und auch das
sollte nicht
vergessen und beiseite getan werden
zu unserer unterstützung gehört auch
dass die bundeswehr bislang 168
besonders schwer verwundete ukrainische
soldaten ausgeflogen und hier in
deutschland behandelt hat
hier helfen als ein umfangreicher weise
und das könnte auch zur kenntnis
genommen werden und nicht durch fragen
und frage gestellt werden die einfach
mit fakten nichts zu tun haben das ist
ja nur eine flucht aus der tatsache dass
die realität mit dem was sie hier in
situ ihren nicht übereinstimmt dass die
fragen stellen um nicht zugeben zu
müssen dass die frage beantworten wäre
und zwar sehr gut
aber es geht weiter
in der letzten woche hat die ukraine den
vertrag mit der rüstungsindustrie über
die gebhard flaig panzer unterzeichnet
die rund dreiwöchige schulung läuft
dieser tage an und
das will ich ausdrücklich sagen die
wurden von der ukraine gewünscht ich
habe in den talkshows dieser republik
gehört das gesagt wurde die wollen das
gar nicht hier im bundestag haben das
auch welche erzählt ganz naseweis haben
sie berichtet wie sie eben über
terminvereinbarung ehrlicherweise dass
barney und zu keinem zeitpunkt richtig
dass es eine hochwirksame eine hoch
schwere waffe um diesen komischen
begriff zu benutzen und sie wird
eingesetzt werden in der ukraine
ein oder andere könnte ja mal seine
ganzen äußerungen die er da in der hitze
des gefechts in diesem fall so gesagt
hat noch einmal überprüfen da ist ganz
schön viel was einfach mit der
wirklichkeit nichts zu tun hat dabei und
es kommt diese waffe mit einer
erstausstattung von 59.000 schuss
munition und das reicht für 1200
bekämpfung vorgänger da habe ich ja auch
wieder welche gehört und gelesen die
gesagt haben dass seine artillerie waffe
mit der man nicht zum beispiel flugzeuge
bekämpft oder drohnen die einen
bedrohung sondern das sei etwas das
einfach dazu nutzt würde in die gegend
zu schießen und anderswo hin dass es
nicht richtig gewesen und trotzdem
durften hier leute überall in
deutschland diesen krams erzählen wo
leben wir eigentlich und was macht
eigentlich das für einen sinn
neben den kunden in den kommenden wochen
werden wir in der ukraine eng abgestimmt
mit den niederländern 12 der modernsten
patz haubitzen der welt liefern die
ausbildung ukrainischer soldaten daran
wird in wenigen tagen abgeschlossen sein
und es sind wirklich sehr moderne waffen
sehr schwere waffen was sollen abgesehen
davon dass das abschießen von flugzeugen
mit luftabwehrraketen auch ein schwerer
vorgang ist aber was soll denn anderes
schwere machte sein als zb gebhard oder
die panzerhaubitze das ist doch einfach
dahergeredet es zeigt dass sie da
vortrag
in den kommenden wochen werden wir der
ukraine eng abgestimmt mit den
niederländer
wenn wir den kommenden wochen werden wir
auch weitere waffen liefern zum beispiel
hat die bundesregierung aktuell
entschieden dass wir mit dem system iris
t das modernste flugabwehrsystem liefern
über das deutschland verfügt damit
versetzen die die ukraine in die lage
eine ganze großstadt vor russischen
luftangriffen zu schützen auch das ist
eine entscheidung dieser bundesregierung
ferner werden wir in der ukraine ein
hochmodernes ordnungs radar liefern das
feindliche auf pizzen börse und rein
kippen atelier aufklärt auch das ist
eine entscheidung die wir getroffen
haben und die die sicherheit der ukraine
mit modernstem gerät sicherstellen wird
alles was sie sagen ist nicht richtig
wir machen das was möglich ist allen
regionen machen
[Applaus]
präsident biden hat gerade eine sehr
sehr lesenswerten und sehr wohl
durchdachten beitragen der new york
times geschrieben
über die unterstützung die die usa
leisten und die verbündeten der usa mit
dem die usa immer eng abgestimmt handeln
das will ich übrigens sagen ist aus
meiner sicht eine wirklich
beeindruckende qualität unserer
transatlantischen beziehungen dass wir
wirklich intensiv miteinander abgestimmt
sind dass wir uns sorgfältig absprechen
dass wir gemeinsam hand hat und
angesichts der verlagerung des gefechts
in den osten der ukraine hat präsident
biden gesagt
man will über das hinaus was bisher
geliefert worden ist
die möglichkeit nutzen mehrfach
raketenwerfer zur verfügung zu stellen
er hat gesagt er
werde keine waffen liefern dass die
ukrainer in der lage wäre nach russland
zu schießen aber das was notwendig ist
mit dann dieser distanz auch von
russland in der ukraine genutzten
solchen raketenwerfern das werden die
usa tun wir sind mit ihr seit tagen
darüber im gespräch und wir haben mit
den usa besprochen dass das was dann
waren unsere technischen möglichkeiten
ist auch beigetragen wird auch das hört
zu unseren entscheidungen
und natürlich ist alleine dieser aufsatz
wert sehr sorgfältig diskutiert zu
werden denn die besonnenheit die
fähigkeit abzuwählen das für und wider
zu
erörtern
das wünschte ich mir auch von der
opposition in diesem deutschen bundestag
hier handle jedenfalls im geleitzug mit
unseren verbündeten so habe ich es oft
gesagt und diesen geleitzug habe ich
eben beschrieben er wird auch weiter
unsere politik bestimmen natürlich weiß
ich dass das eine situation ist in der
das für und wider mit großen heißem
herzen wird aber es gibt auch klare
haltungen dabei und natürlich ist es gut
sich hinzustellen und zudem zu gehören
die immer sagen alles noch mehr davon
noch was davon noch was genau so wie es
ganz einfach ist zu sagen gar nichts
aber das was man tun muss ist genau der
weg den diese regierung eingeschlagen
hat große entschlossenheit mut und kluge
abwägungen das ist das was räte die
und damit bin ich bei dem liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
was wir mit dem sondervermögen für die
bundeswehr erreichen
ziel ist eine leistungsfähige und
fortschrittliche bundeswehr eine
bundeswehr die ein kernauftrag die
landes- und bündnisverteidigung erfüllen
kann weil sie ausreichend ausgestattet
es und ich wiederhole was sich am anfang
gesagt habe die versäumnisse der letzten
16 jahren von csu und cdu
verteidigungsminister und der dortigen
behörden die werden jetzt aufgearbeitet
und aufgeholt
das weiß jeder
es war die csu cdu cdu geht die spart
zeit bei der bundeswehr begonnen haben
das ist die wahrheit
ich bedanke mich bei allen die in den
letzten tagen mitgeholfen haben dass wir
diese entscheidung zustande bringen
können das so kommt zum tiefen und da
über parteigrenzen hinweg verhandelt
worden ist denn das was hier hinbekommen
ist ein quantensprung
und es hat auch eine konsequenz die
bundeswehr wird wohl dann die größte
konventionelle armee im europäischen
nato system
und wir werden auch alles dafür
beitragen dass wir uns auch ansonsten
weiter verbessern was unsere
sicherheitsarchitektur betrifft zum
beispiel wenn es um fragen der
cybersicherheit geht und deshalb finde
ich müssen wir den moment der hier
stattfindet auch genau verstehen es ist
anders als in früheren zeiten wo man in
paris sind warschau in london in
washington oder prag angst und sorge
hatte wenn die bundeswehr so viel
stärker wahr und die deutsche armee
sondern es ist erleichterung was dort zu
spüren ist alle sind sehr beeindruckt
von diesem schritt endlich sagen sie
endlich übernimmt deutschland die
sicherheitspolitische verantwortung die
es im einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert
hatte und zwar von einer ampel angehören
wie wir wollen helfen
ist die richtige antwort auf die
zeitenwende und hier geben sie die wir
kolleginnen und kollegen wir bringen in
ordnung was nicht in ordnung war und
deshalb ist es auch so richtig bei
unsere soldatinnen und soldaten es
verdienen dass sie eine gute bundeswehr
haben genauso wie die bürgerinnen und
bürger des landes denn es geht um
sicherheit und wir haben die
verantwortung die sicherheit unseres
landes und unseres bündnisses zu
gewährleisten
herberg sie haben darüber berichtet dass
hier als ich das sagte beifall
geklatscht wurde auch aus den reihen
ihrer fraktion dafür bedanke ich mich
wie ich mich übrigens wirklich ernstlich
gedanke dass es möglich war konstruktiv
das ergebnis hier zu verhandeln ich
möchte mich auch bei allen die mit
verhandelt haben intensiv bedanken weil
ich weiß es geht immer auch in konkrete
person in der lage sind dank das zu tun
was notwendig ist aber das
paradies
das will ich an dieser stelle dann doch
auch sagen so zu tun
so zu tun
als wäre das jetzt alles schon mal
passiert weil die rede gehalten wurde
vor drei monaten
das ist ein irrtum das ist die größte
veränderung der sicherheitspolitischen
architektur dieses landes und ich bin
stolz dass wir das diese regierung sie
auf den weg bringen kann ich bin dankbar
dass die opposition dabei hilft
[Applaus]
1 will ich hier noch kurz sagen weil das
für mich wichtig ist
internationale solidarität ist keine
einbahnstraße
und deshalb
habe ich sehr bewusst die aufstrebenden
demokratien des globalen südens indien
indonesien südafrika senegal und
argentinien als partnerländer zum g 7
gipfel in ellmau eingelegt
denn das darf uns nicht passieren
dass wir diese länder als bündnispartner
verlieren und das ist ja eine große
gefahr angesichts der auswirkung des
krieges ist der gefahren für hunger und
sicherheit und energieversorgung dieser
länder und deshalb ist es wichtig dass
wir darüber nicht hinweg sehen der krieg
ist aus der perspektive mancher dieser
länder ganz weit weg aber die
konsequenzen ganz nah wir müssen ihnen
helfen und das werden wir tun in größter
solidarität und gleichzeitig die
botschaft aussenden die auch ausgesandt
werden muss in jedem gespräch es ist
putins krieg der diese krise verursacht
und nichts anderes
[Applaus]
wir leben mit einer herausforderung wie
sie die bundesrepublik deutschland noch
nicht in dieser art gekannt hat wir
müssen etwas dafür tun dass wir in
dieser besonderen situation auch
besonders handle und dass durch diese
haushalt auszahlen das sind nicht meine
worte sondern die worte meiner
vorgängerin aus dem jahr 2020
seinerzeit hat die bundeskanzler und
damit eine neuverschuldung begründet die
deutlich höher lag als die
neuverschuldung im aktuellen
haushaltsentwurf
anders als damals haben wir es heute
allerdings nicht nur mit der pandemie
und ihren folgen zu tun sondern
zusätzlich mit einem krieg in europa mit
einer globalen energie- und
nahrungsmittelkrise und weltweit
steigenden preisen in diesen unsicheren
zeiten sorgen wir mit dem haushalt 2022
und dem sondervermögen bundeswehr für
sicherheit und zugleich stellen wir die
weichen für den aufbruch in die zukunft
das erwarten die bürgerinnen und bürger
dafür steht die bundesregierung dafür
steht dieser ausland schön dann
wenn diese debatte ein boxkampf wäre
dann kann man nicht anders sagen als
dass olaf scholz sehr angeschlagen
zunächst in seine rede ging ein
wirkungsbereichen sie gibt des
oppositionschefs denn voller stolz hielt
im märz entgegen sie stellen nur fragen
positionieren sich aber nicht der
bundeskanzler hat zu fragen des
oppositionschefs nicht beantwortet wer
hat darauf hingewiesen dass das
rentenniveau bei 48 prozent stabilisiert
wird er hat zum krieg gesagt gib ihnen
darf diesen krieg nicht gewinnen und
wird ihn auch nicht gewinnen und hat
dann gesagt es sei überheblich von merz
und fehl am platze über die ukraine zu
entscheiden die und keiner und die
kleineren würden selbst entscheiden
das hatte eigentlich gar nicht in frage
gestellt zum archivieren ja gesagt hat
das kriegsziel für ihn ist ganz klar der
status quo vor dem 24 februar dieser
äußerung gibt es ja der bundeskanzler
hat angekündigt eine konzertierte aktion
wie die erstmals 1967 beginnen nachdem
nach der wirtschaftskrise 19 66 67 von
seinem parteifreund karl schiller ins
leben gerufen wurde also sich
zusammenzusetzen mit gewerkschaften
arbeitgebern und start um gegen die
rekord preisgegeben die preisentwicklung
vorzugehen der bundeskanzler zur
bewaffnung auch mal gesagt material
würdige liefert eine neuigkeit hierbei
ist dass offensichtlich moderne
flugabwehrsystem an die ukraine
geliefert werden soll und ein
ordnungsrahmen radar wann das der fall
sein soll das hat der bundeskanzler
nicht gesagt er alles weiter wie die
damen und herren es ist sehr schön dass
sie sich zwischen opposition und
regierung so gut verstehen dass sie zu
einem kompromiss gefunden haben aber uns
liegen alle diese anträge gar nicht vor
haben wir hier geschlafen oder am sie
geschlafen was ist ja eigentlich los
legen sie doch die anträge vor dass wir
sie auch hier vernünftig abstimmen
können
aber zurück zum haushalt ist eine
haushaltsdebatte wenig hat herr merz
über den haushalt geredet aber diese
haushalt ist ein dokument der
abgehobenheit der realitätsverweigerung
und der ignoranz gegenüber dem zustand
des landes und seiner menschen
die regierungskoalition muss sich an die
welt zu retten die energieversorgung für
ein industrieland im alleingang neu zu
regeln und das klima in 50 oder 100
jahren zu regeln aber das eigene land
und seine menschen werden ruiniert
sie reden von zeitenwende aber sie
handeln nicht danach die kapseln sich in
ihrer ideologischen fantastereien ein
von klimaschutz energiewende
multikulturalismus diversität und
verweigern den blick auf die realität
deutschland steckt in einer
fundamentalen wirtschafts- finanz- und
staatskrise die alles bisher dagewesene
übertrifft
und dennoch
und dennoch geben sie das geld mit
vollen händen aus sie verteilen es in
alle welt klima milliarden für ihn denn
hier
milliarden waffen milliarden für die
ukraine darf sie bleiben den
staatsapparat noch weiter auf sie
schaffen neue regierungsposten und
genehmigen sich großzügig noch mehr
stellen in den ministerien und
verwaltung für die eigenen bürger und
steuerzahler bleiben dagegen nur
trostpflaster und alibi politik die
deutschen zahlen mit die höchsten
steuern und abgaben der westlichen welt
sie bekommen dafür
miserable renten und einen zunehmenden
funktionsfähigen staat einen staat der
immer weniger in der lage ist seine
kernaufgaben wahrzunehmen die
aufrechterhaltung von
rechtsstaatlichkeit und öffentliche
ordnung die gewährleistung von innerer
und äußerer sicherheit der sich aber
immer dreister und über griffiger in das
privatleben der bürger einmischt sie
bevormundet und ihn dafür immer tiefer
in die tasche greift die krise in der
unser land steckt ist nicht vom himmel
gefallen sie ist politisch gemacht
inflation energieknappheit
explodierender energiepreise
gestörte lieferketten fachkräftemangel
und überlastete sozialkassen sind die
folge politischer fehlentscheidungen und
nein sie können die verantwortung dafür
nicht allein auf putins angriffskrieg
schieben die ursachen liegen tiefer die
fatalen fehlentscheidungen wurden früher
getroffen und sie sind vor allem in
berlin und brüssel gefallen die
galoppierende inflation ist die quittung
für exzessive schulden machen und für
die geldschwemme und null zinspolitik
der europäischen zentralbank zur
subventionierung der euro hoch
schuldenstaaten 8 prozent inflation
heißt sparguthaben
rücklagen und rentenansprüche sind nach
sechs jahren nur noch die hälfte wert
die reallöhne sinken als folge der
inflation fast 40 prozent der deutschen
wissen gar nicht mehr wie sie ihren
lebensunterhalt bestreiten sollen was
haben sie dazu eigentlich gesagt was
haben sie an lösung angeboten nichts
noch mehr bürokratische umverteilung ist
alles was diese ampel anzubieten hat
tank rabatt nur ein euro ticket einmal
zuschüsse oder klima geld sind teure
bürokratische strohfeuer die nichts
bringen und ich muss es einfach so sagen
die nur ihre eigene unfähigkeit
kaschieren soll
steigen der energiepreise heizen die
inflation weiter an und treiben
mittelstand und mittelschicht in die
farmer die deutsche energie krise hat
einer die energiewende kohle und atom
ausstieg zeitgleich flattr strom aus
wind und sonne als ersatz für eine
grundlastfähige günstige
energieversorgung wie wir sie einmal
hatten in diesem land und dazu als
neueste idee aus dem hause habe die
beseitigung der erdgasinfrastruktur für
die wohnungs beheizung das konnte und
das kann nicht gut gehen sie aber
missbrauchen den krieg in der ukraine
um diesem weg noch zu beschleunigen noch
mehr geld dafür zu verbrennen und noch
mehr naturzerstörung durch monströse
windräder voranzutreiben die deutschen
energiekosten sind jetzt schon die
höchsten aller industrieländer ob mit
oder ohne ukraine krieg die energiewende
ist gescheitert und muss schleunigst
korrigiert werden und dazu muss die
erkenntnis kommen dass energie sanktion
gegen russland
kontraproduktiv sind und unserem land
mehr schaden zufügen als russland sehr
geehrte damen und herren und durch den
freiwilligen verzicht auf erdöl
lieferungen auf dem landweg das muss man
sich mal vorstellen
gefährden sie die treibstoffversorgung
im osten deutschlands und würden den
bürgern noch höhere energiepreise auf
den drohenden zusammenbruch der sozialen
sicherungssysteme vor dem der
bundesrechnungshof gerade in einem alarm
bericht gewarnt hat haben sie ebenfalls
keine antwort
unkontrollierte migration
löst weder fachkräftemangel noch
demografieprobleme und schon gar nicht
wenn man wahllos migration von
bildungsfernen und nicht integrierbaren
aus fremden kulturkreisen zulässt und
sogar noch fördert dagegen sind im
vergangenen jahr
menschen aus deutschland
ausgewandert nicht wenige sind
hochqualifizierte die für immer verloren
sind und dieser brain drain
diesem brain brain nehmen sie
achselzuckend hin und fahren fort mit
der negativen anreiz setzung für
qualifizierte arbeitnehmer so sieht die
politik aus und von den asyl zuwanderern
seit 2016 stichwort wir schaffen das
sind rund eine million immer noch eine
million zusätzliche kost gänger in
unseren sozialsystemen
was tun sie sie funktionieren die hartz
iv
leistungen durch streichung der
sanktionsmöglichkeiten zum de facto
grundeinkommen um und sie wollen diese
leistung im nächsten schritt nicht nur
für ukrainische
kriegsflüchtlinge sondern für alle asyl
einwanderer öffnen das heißt sie
beschleunigen diesen trend und
qualifizierte einwanderung und wer
dagegen 45 jahre bei einem durchschnitts
bruttolohn von
24.000 euro im jahr gearbeitet hat
landet gerade auf einem hartz iv niveau
und sie tun nichts um diese
offensichtliche schieflage zu beseitigen
und das rentensystem auf eine tragfähige
grundlage zu stellen und das ist der
offenbarungseid für die
sozialdemokratisch geführte andere
begegnung
wir brauchen
tatsächlich eine echte zeitenwende in
der deutschen politik und das bedeutet
abschied von ideologischen illusion und
konzentration der staatsaufgaben und
ausgaben auf das wesentliche es ist
richtig und überfällig den auf rüstungs
und
investitionsstau der bundeswehr mit
zusätzlichen ausgaben anzugehen
jahrzehntelang wurde die armee
vernachlässigt und
heruntergewirtschaftet dafür tragen sie
alle vor allem aber ihre partei herr
merz die verantwortung 16 jahre lang hat
die union kanzlerin und
verteidigungsminister gestellt da ist es
schon mehr als scheinheilig sich hier
als retter und beschützer der bundeswehr
auf zu spielen und den soli und
den soli wr märz dass sie eben dargelegt
hat um zu funktionieren als sondersteuer
zur reparatur der eigens
heruntergewirtschafteten bundeswehr das
ist ein schlag ins gesicht für alle
steuerzahler
die bezeichnung sondervermögen für
zusätzliche schulden ist ebenfalls
irreführend warum nennt sie das
sondervermögen es sind sonder schulden
und das wäre ehrlicher dass diese
ausgabe im grundgesetz verankert werden
soll um sie aus der allgemeinen
staatsverschuldung hinaus zu rechnen ist
ein unnötiger und unlauterer bilanztrick
und das wissen sie ganz genau und besser
werden und dafür steht die afd
überflüssige posten aus dem haushalt zu
streichen die sprechen hier von einem
rekordvolumen des haushaltes streichen
sie überflüssige posten und
konzentrieren sie die staatsausgaben auf
das wesentliche und niemand kann
behaupten dass dafür keine spielräume
vorhanden wären der staat hat den
deutschland nicht zu wenig geld sondern
zu viel das verstehen sich vielleicht
das konzept und ersetzt bei diesen
ausgaben die falschen prioritäten darum
geht es doch und der auf das vierfache
des vor krone haushalts
aufgeblasene etat des
gesundheitsministeriums
ist durch nichts zu rechtfertigen der
überforderte gesundheitsminister darf
also weiter milliarden nicht benötigter
impfdosen bestellen und anlasslose
massentest um veranlassen und unser land
hat gerade wahrhaftig andere sorgen als
die neuauflage fakten freier grundrechts
einschränkungen und rechtswidriger ins
kampagnen
viel geld wieder ausgegeben für
zensurmaßnahmen meinungs- kontrolle da
sind sie ja spitzenreiter und den
sogenannten kampf gegen rechts drängende
echte sicherheitsprobleme werden dagegen
herunter gespielt vor allem wenn es sich
um die importierte kriminalität handelt
deutschland braucht weder neue steuern
noch neue schulden um wieder auf die
beine zu kommen wir brauchen die
rückkehr zu soliden staatsfinanzen und
das erfordert mehr als folgenlose tweets
dieses bundesfinanzministers stammt
lieber einige lieblingsprojekte grüne
und linke ideologie und klientelpolitik
ein dann haben wir auch geld zur
entlastung der menschen und lassen wir
den bürgern ihr sauer verdientes geld in
ihrem eigenen portemonnaie dort ist es
am besten aufgehoben
gebt mir den bürgerlichen und
unternehmerischen
der unternehmerischen freiheit
wieder vorrang statt bevormundung und
kontrollwahn liebe ampel koalition und
gehen wir zurück zur realpolitik
setzen die interessen des eigenen landes
genau dahin wo sie hingehören und zwar
an die erste stelle ich bin
alles weil die fraktionschefin der afg
hat gesagt dieser haushalt ignoranz
gegen ist ignoranz gegen zustände und
menschen im eigenen land das
sondervermögen das sein sonder schulden
ein unlauter bilanztrick und besser
überflüssige posten aus dem haushalt zu
streichen als solche finanztricks
anzuwenden ist ihr rat deutschland
brauche keine neuen schulden oder neue
steuern man müsse nur die gelingt links
grüne klientel politik stoppen die
brille man jetzt die co
fraktionsvorsitzende der bündnisgrünen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren bei der weder von herrn
merz habe ich gedacht die überschrift
lautet sagt einer dessen
bundestagsfraktion und bundesregierung
16 jahre verantwortung getragen hat und
uns allen im parlament und der
gesellschaft einen
riesenberg nicht erledigte aufgaben
hinterlassen hat meine damen und herren
herr merz ich weiß ich woher hdf
vielleicht doch im plenum oder nach
getaner rede schon weg aber
ein bisschen weniger männer eitelkeit
ein bisschen mehr selbstreflexion und
vor allen dingen meine damen und herren
ein bisschen mehr
gemeinsame verantwortung angesichts
dieser wirklich krisenhaften zeit wäre
notwendig und wichtig und angemessen
der erste kolleginnen und kollegen seit
fast 100 tagen trug putins angriffskrieg
in der ukraine
es kann keine aussprache geben um ohne
diesem thema eine große relevanz eine
große aufmerksamkeit zu widmen denn die
lage ist dramatisch morde an
ukrainischen zivilistinnen
vergewaltigung vertreibung massive
menschenrechtsverletzungen durch die
russische seite sind kriegsalltag
geworden und die große sorge treibt
wahrscheinlich nicht nur mich sondern
uns alle um es gibt irgendwie eine
gewisse gewöhnung an das an dass sich
niemand gewinnen darf nämlich diese
grausamkeit dieses krieges
putin
obwohl er die offensive in den letzten
tagen deutlich erhöht hat seine
kriegsziele nicht erreicht und das liegt
an der ukraine angeben an der art wie
die ukraine durchhält wie sie kämpft die
zeit läuft gegen putin mit jedem
weiteren tag die menschen in der ukraine
kämpfen und verteidigen ihr land ihre
demokratie ihre freiheit und russland
muss diesen krieg sofort stoppen und
alle kampfhandlungen einstellen dass es
eine wichtige forderung europas aller
der weltgemeinschaft auch nach fast 100
tagen krieg meine damen und herren hügel
führt nicht nur den krieg gegen die
ukraine sondern auch gegen unsere
gemeinsamen europäischen und
internationalen werte menschenrechte
demokratie freiheit selbstbestimmung
dafür kämpft die ukraine und wir werden
nicht akzeptieren dass putin die
europäische friedensordnung zerstört mit
dem recht des stärkeren grenzen zu
verschieben mit hoher die welt in
geiselhaft zu nehmen oder das rad der
geschichte zurückdrehen zu wollen und
deshalb meine damen und herren darf
putin diesen krieg nicht gewinnen wie es
wichtig an dieser stelle noch einmal
deutlich zu sagen wir stehen an der
seite der ukraine ja wir machen uns die
daraus folgenden entscheidungen nicht
leicht wir nehmen die sorgen und nöte
und ängste vor einer ausweitung des
krieges sehr ernst auch wir hadern
manchmal auch wir wägen ab und ja
vielleicht
finden manche entscheidungen auch
schneller getroffen werden
aber wir stehen an der seite der ukraine
und sagen ja zum recht auf
selbstverteidigung und zu
waffenlieferung zu schweren bach
lieferung zu denen wir ja gesagt haben
sie gebraucht werden dringend gebraucht
werden und die zugesagt sind und auf den
weg gebracht werden meine damen und
herren wir sagen ja zu weiteren
sanktionen zum ende fossiler energien
aus russland es ist wichtig dass der
beschluss zum öl embargo endlich kommt
er hat lange gedauert aber jetzt ist er
da die rolle ungarns ist unrühmlich das
wissen wir alle aber wir werden die
ukraine jetzt weiter unterstützen beim
wiederaufbau und bei ihren weg in die
europäische gemeinschaft das ist klar
und auch dieses signal ist eindeutig von
uns hier im parlament ausgegangen und
auch hier
kommen wir jetzt zu der frage deutsche
tragen besondere verantwortung für
frieden in europa und hier herr merz ich
meine es darf doch nicht ihr ernst sein
ein soli für die bundeswehr meine damen
und herren 16 jahre
regierungsverantwortung die gott sei
dank vorbei sind ein volley für die
bundeswehr nachdem man die wunde wer so
abgewirtschaftet hat mit allen
entscheidungen allen
verteidigungsministern der cdu/csu in
den letzten 16 jahren ich hätte mir mehr
verantwortung von ihnen gewünscht dass
es klar und eindeutig wie deutsche
tragen eine besondere verantwortung für
frieden in europa unsere nachbarn
verbündete schauen auf uns erwarten
klarheit entschlossenheit und
gemeinsames handeln und auch deshalb ist
es wichtig dass dieser für uns nicht
einfacher kompromiss zum sondervermögen
jetzt gelungen ist und ausgehandelt ist
ein scheitern wäre keine option gewesen
meine damen und herren und das wissen
alle auch wenn ich als grüne
bundestagsfraktion ganz klar gesagt habe
die vorliegende fassung des kabinetts
wäre die bessere grundlage gewesen aber
es war klar wir brauchen eine zwei
drittel mehrheit im bundestag und
deshalb ist es wichtig und richtig dass
es hier zu einem ergebnis zu kommen ist
ich nehme zur kenntnis dass leute wie
manfred weber weiter sind als ihre ganze
fraktion und allen voran als ihr
vorsitzender
trend jetzt darauf was wir eigentlich
verankern wollten die europäische
verteidigung und die cyber abwehr und
das nicht einfach nur benennt im test
sondern durch geld hinterlegt das schild
manchen jetzt sehr spät ein wir grüne
fordern seit monaten eine cyber
sicherheitsstrategie mehr geld für den
zivilschutz an uns wird es nicht
scheitern das ist dringend notwendig in
dieser erweiterten sicherheitsbegriff
was die bündnisfähigkeit wann gehen ist
dringend notwendig sie sind weit weit
hinter der aktuellen debatte in
deutschland und in europa meine damen
ihr unten die einigung unterstreicht
dass die notlage eine einigung zum
sondervermögen außerhalb der
schuldenbremse dann doch möglich machen
bitte wir haben gerade gehört was herr
merz zu der frage schuldenbremse gesagt
hat wir haben auch gehört was er zu der
frage sondervermögen gesagt hat
schlüssig ist das alles nicht meine
damen und herren wir jetzt sind
der lage ein sondervermögen aufzubauen
für die bundeswehr geht's der etf also
der energie- und klimafonds mit den 60
milliarden wird beim
bundesverfassungsgericht beklagt
gleichzeitig gleichzeitig lässt man ihn
aber stehen und nimmt ihn verdeckung
sämtlicher projekte der union so
funktioniert haushaltsberatung
cdu/csu meine damen und herren aber wir
stehen vor ganz anderen
herausforderungen
und jetzt wird der union zu beschäftigen
auf dem weiteren weg werden wir zusammen
hier im haus hier in unserem land
darüber diskutieren müssen wie wir
unserer verantwortung besser gerecht
werden bei der wahrung von frieden und
sicherheit beim schutz der
menschenrechte bei der globalen
entwicklung beim globalen klimaschutz
und ich bin dankbar dass hier annalena
baerbock erste wegmarken gesetzt hat mit
der nationalen sicherheitsstrategie ich
bin auch dankbar dass robert habe in den
letzten tagen klar gesagt hat dass
investitionsgarantien
verweigert werden nachdem deutlich wurde
welche gravierenden
menschenrechtsverletzungen in china an
den abo-gebühren
begangen werden es ist deutlich geworden
es ist an der zeit klare haltung klaren
kompass und entschlossenes handeln zu
zeigen hier und jetzt und das tun wir in
dieser woche und unterstreichen das
nicht nur durch die beiden
entlastungspaket 'nicht nur durch die
sehr schwierige debatte zum
sondervermögen sondern auch durch die
entlastungs paket und den haushalt die
wir jetzt auf den weg bringen gemeinsam
als ampera der mensch dem land spüren
dass die
groß sind und das ist eine gemeinsame
verantwortung bräuchte mehr gemeinsame
verantwortung bräuchte diese krisen zu
bewältigen
jeder in seinem lebensalltag spürt es an
der kasse im supermarkt oder bei der
nebenkostenabrechnung und in dem kontext
da olaf scholz für die konzertierte
aktion angesprochen hat was ist das
angesichts der lage für ein signal wenn
ein großer wohnungsbaukonzern heute
ankündigt die mieten zu erhöhen ist dass
das signal einer sozialen
marktwirtschaft nein das ist es nicht
meine damen und herren wir haben zwei
große entlastungs paket auf den weg
gebracht als ampelkoalition viele
maßnahmen wie etwa das nur ein euro
ticket greifen ab heute 7 millionen
verkaufte tickets meine damen und herren
sie sehen die menschen wollen dass es
angebote gibt dem öffentlichen
personennahverkehr dass die bezahlbar
sind dann werden sie auch benutzt das
ist eine riesenchance für uns hier auf
umzusteuern noch dringend notwendig ist
wir helfen mit den entlastungs paketen
gezielt vor armut betroffenen kindern
mit einem sofort zuschlag von 20 euro
erwachsene in der grundsicherung mit
einer einmalzahlung von 200 euro
jedes kind in familien 1100 euro das
wird ein einmaliger heizkostenzuschuss
in höhe von 270 euro aus gezeigt und in
der breite entlasten wir mit der
anhebung des grundfreibetrags der
energiepreis pauschale oder dem neuen
euro ticket allein
diesem jahr sind das entlastung für
bürgerinnen und bürger von weit über 30
milliarden euro meine damen und herren
und das ist ein wichtiges signal in
krisenzeiten an die bürgerinnen und
bürger und ich bin froh dass wir das als
anti gemeinsam auf den weg bringen eine
daraus hervor ohne putin
die klimakrise und die notwendige
soziale und ökologische transformation
wie wir haben verantwortung in dieser
krise übernommen und tun unser
möglichstes
und das ist mit aller ernsthaftigkeit zu
tun wir wissen aber auch dass wir an
vielen anderen stellen dranbleiben
müssen dass wir da liefern müssen es ist
eine vielzahl der herausforderung die
zum handeln drängen und es ist auch der
berg den uns die union in 16 jahren
nicht erledigte aufgaben hinterlassen
hat der uns jetzt drängt meine damen und
herren die unmittelbaren trust wurde
sind das eine die ampel drin nötige
strukturelle veränderungen auf dem weg
die abschaffung der eeg umlage oder eben
die einführung des gesetzlichen
mindestlohns
alles sehr wichtige sozialpolitische
maßnahmen um die notwendige
transformation zu begleiten und das ist
ein wichtiges signal an bürgerinnen und
bürger und weitere strukturelle
entlastung reformen liegen vor uns jedes
fünfte kind wird den da mut die
kindergrundsicherung muss eingeführt
werden wir haben riesenglück sowohl in
der frage der zukunft der renten
versicherung als auch der
gesundheitsversorgung als auch der
pflegeversicherung übernommen
unterkommen 7 und fordern diese
regierung auf in der rente was zu tun wo
sie eigentlich die letzten 16 jahre
meine damen und herren
strukturen sind notwendig ja es ist die
schweiz aber struktur reform sind
notwendig und die lücke in der gkv von
20 milliarden euro die hätten sie
verursacht und nicht mehr und
[Applaus]
erwarten
die sorgen sind sieben ein paar
vorschläge zur rente wo leben sie den
herrn ihr habt sie mal 16 jahre taten
star arbeit ihre aufgabe
und viele sich auch nicht durch ein plan
ja dafür sorgen ihre aufgabe weil wenn
sie verantwortung tragen
in dieser situation in dieser krise dank
ist es ihre aufgabe diese
krisenbewältigung mitzutragen diese
erwartung hat mich an sie als
demokratische fraktion und meine damen
und herren
das was einen notwendigen
strukturreformen
wirklich vor uns liegt eben fragen der
ökologischen transformation in fragen
der sozialen transformation ist nicht
durch ein halbes jahr regierung mal
gerade zu regeln und deshalb habe ich
auch gerade herr merz an ihre
verantwortung appelliert ich meine das
ganz ernst ganz große gesellschaftliche
aufgaben da sollten auch sie
verantwortung tragen denn wir sind zum
teil in dem schlamassel weil sie ihn
nicht bewältigt haben weil sie
weggeguckt haben und das geht zum
beispiel gerade die bekämpfung der
klimakrise an wo waren sie denn die
letzten 16 jahre wir haben ist alle
gewusst dass ein umsteuern dringend
notwendig gewesen wäre der ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien wurde blockiert
die energie effizienz nicht
vorangebracht
energieeinsparung nicht nein sie haben
uns in diese zementierte abhängigkeit
der fossilien daran sind die vielen
entscheidung und kein geld zwei liegt in
so viele große baustellen gerade vor uns
wir können doch nicht darüber hinweg
sehen was sie in ihren in pakistan die
hitzerekorde die durch die wetter-
extreme selbst bei uns wir haben
dramatische folgen und wir haben vor
allen dingen den auftrag des
bundesverfassungsgerichtes ganz klar als
aufgabe für das parlament uns hier
gesetzt bekommen auch sie die bekämpfung
der klimakrise die frage der künftigen
generationen und ihrer freiheit ist bei
allen künftigen entscheidungen zu wahren
und zu belasten das ist unser auftrag
und den akten
verweigert ein so gelassen wie heute
meiden backen nicht so auf sondern tut
sie mit das wäre angesagt und meine
damen und herren wenn ich an diese
ganzen wirklich relevanten und großen
veränderungen denke dann ist doch klar
dass das nicht durch ein paar
einsparungen hier oder da oder zwei
bekenntnisse zur schuldenbremse zu
regeln ist wir sind in einer notlage und
wir werden überlegen müssen wie wir aus
dieser notlage mit
zukunftsinvestitionen rauskommen das ist
die zentrale frage meine damen und
herren und daher redet hier und heute
und für die zukunft und wir haben im
bereich der internationalen
verpflichtungen menge akzente gesetzt in
diesem haushalt aber bei einem 1 zu 1
prinzip sind wir noch nicht und deshalb
geht es auch um die globale
verantwortung für uns alle darüber wird
weiter zu diskutieren sein ich halte es
für dringend geboten das mit klaren
kompass klarer haltung und
entschlossenem handeln für die zukunft
in den nächsten monaten es weitergeht
und wir klare aufgaben vor uns liegen
die zu tun sind machen sie mit
entscheiden sie sich dafür auch
verantwortung zu übernehmen sie müssen
sie eigentlich spüren aus den letzten 16
jahren untätigkeit
britta haßelmann die co
fraktionsvorsitzende
der bündnisgrünen hat hier für dich märz
und der union noch mal ein spiegel
vorgehalten und gesagt er hat er die
letzten 16 jahre
regiert überall lücken bei der rente bei
den zukunft system der
krankenversicherung
alles habe dieser alten bundesregierung
russland muss den krieg sofort stoppen
putin führt einen krieg auch gegen
unsere gemeinsamen europäischen werte
wir stehen an der seite der ukraine auch
ein klares jahr zu schweren waffen die
nächste rednerin hier in der
generaldebatte des deutschen bundestages
in der haushaltswoche amir adnani co
vorsitzende der linksfraktion
die dinge des täglichen bedarfs
man kann nicht mehr von einer minderheit
sprechen das sagte anja pohl vorrecht
einer sendung börse vor acht butter
kostet inzwischen über drei euro seien
wohl 05 euro milch im discounter schon
ein euro 20 frisches obst und gemüse
werden zunehmend zum luxusgut
eine solche preissteigerung habe ich
seit langer zeit nicht mehr erlebt das
sagte mir neulich einen 93 jährige dame
aus meinem wahlkreis zum glück zurück
fahre sie kein auto mehr sagte sie die
spritpreise heute könnte sie mit ihrer
kleinen rente nicht bezahlen das neue
euro ticket das hält sie für eine gute
idee aber wo sie wohnt er fährt fast
kein bus und nicht so wie man sich das
chaos in der umsetzung mal anschaut dann
könnte man meinen an die steuer sei noch
im amt
100 euro in der die pauschale wird sie
als rentnerin auch nichts sehen anders
übrigens als minister minister der
bundesregierung auch sie herr chance sie
bekommen die energie pauschale die alte
dame nicht ja wie abgehoben kann man
eigentlich sein dass sowohl in skandal
und da wundern sie sich dass viele leute
nicht mit so dagegen weil sie das
vertrauen in politik verloren haben
solche gesetze schreiben die spaltung
der gesellschaft voran herr scholz das
müssen doch auch sie inzwischen mal mehr
wir haben seit über zwei jahren mit den
auswirkungen der korona pandemie zu
kämpfen viele menschen sind ausgelaugt
die bundesregierung hat immer noch
keinen plan herr lauterbach früchte tja
das im herbst die infektionszahlen
wieder nach oben gehen könnten sind wir
darauf eigentlich vorbereitet gibt es
inzwischen zum beispiel noch personal in
den krankenhäusern
ich werde ihnen sagen nein woher soll es
auch kommen sie haben nichts aber auch
gar nichts an den schlechten
arbeitsbedingungen für die pflegerinnen
und pfleger verbessert nicht mal den
pflege bonus haben alle bekommen aber
von nichts kommt nun mal nichts herr
lauterbach
viele menschen
viele menschen blicken mit großer sorge
in die zukunft so unsicher wie jetzt war
das leben hierzulande lange nicht mehr
zwei flugstunden von uns entfernt doch
putins krieg in der ukraine seit über
drei monaten sterben dort tag für tag
menschen tausende sind auf der flucht
die weitere entwicklung und auch die
auswirkungen sind vollkommen ungewiss
außerdem geht der klimawandel weit gehen
und gebremst voran auch eher befördert
die soziale spaltung hierzulande und in
der welt fakt ist diese bundesregierung
gibt keine sozialen antworten auf die
krisen unserer zeit und das geht so
nicht kollegen
beginnen wir mit den steigenden
lebenshaltungskosten hier braucht es
dringend eine wirksame staatliche
preisaufsicht für lebensmittel energie
damit schluss ist mit den mondpreisen es
braucht direktzahlungen die realen
preissteigerungen auch wirklich abfedern
es braucht einen schutzschirm die
betroffenen unternehmen und beschäftigte
gerade auch im hinblick auf das
bevorstehende öl embargo das die lage ja
deutlich verschärfen wird es braucht
eine echte offensive zur schaffung von
bezahlbarem wohnraum besonders in
ballungsgebieten den wohnraum darf kein
luxus sein es ist ein menschenrecht und
ja und ja wir brauchen entschlossene
maßnahmen im kampf gegen den klimawandel
aber dafür muss man auch bereit sein in
klimaschutz zu investieren in die
notwendige transformation vor allem in
die dekarbonisierung der wirtschaft in
erneuerbare energien all das muss aber
auch einher gehen mit klaren
perspektiven und sicherung von
arbeitsplätzen
klimaschutz der kann nur gelingen wenn
er sozial gerecht ist dass sie waren
aber
macht stattdessen die bundesbank für
keine der aufgezeigten probleme sind im
haushalt auch nur ansatzweise genügend
mittel eingestellt im bereich sozialen
wohnungsbau wissen sie ja nicht mal wie
es hier die einstellen müssten um ihre
zahl von 100.000 sozialwohnungen
projektor erreichen dass an eine anfrage
meiner kollegin karin rein aus gedeckt
ist wirklich ein skandal
die explodierenden energiekosten
gibt es flüchtige entlastungs päckchen
die realen mehrkosten werden nicht mal
im ansatz ausgeglichen einmalig bis zu
300 euro das lächerlich studierende
reden aber dem rentner wie gesagt gegen
komplett leer aus das einfach unerhört
und robert heil der will jetzt mit einem
sozial gestaffelten klima geld
nachbessern schön aber davon müssen sie
halt erstmal ihr eigenes kabinett
überzeugen da kommt ja jetzt schon eine
menge gegenwind und selbst wenn es
kommen sollte dann frühestens anfang
nächsten jahres in welcher höhe keiner
weiß ist wirklich absurd kollegen
kollegen
bei all dem
darf man sich doch zu recht für wen
machen sie eigentlich politik meine
damen und herren von der anblick für die
38 prozent der menschen in unserem land
die kaum noch über die runden kommen
sicher nicht aber
es gibt durchaus leute die von ihrer
politik profitieren die aktionäre von
den energiekonzernen zb die freuen sich
gerade über rekordgewinne der ölmulti
shell hat gerade verkündet dass seine
gewinne um 43 prozent gestiegen sind man
könnte diese krassen krisen gewinne
steuerlich abschriften das macht italien
zum beispiel wir haben das als linke
hier mehrfach eingebracht mit diesen
steuerlichen mehreinnahmen könnte man
die menschen entlasten wirtschaft
scheint für sie unvorstellbar ich bin so
unglaublich
er wissen sie alle alle superreichen in
deutschland können sich darauf verlassen
dass diese bundesregierung unter ihnen
unter keinen umständen an das prall
gefüllte bankkonto geht und zwar egal
wie groß die not ist denn wo ist die
vermögenssteuer wie der spd liebe grünen
im wahlkampf waren sie danach voll dafür
da haben sie doch noch verstanden dass
zum beispiel der lidl chef schwarz
dessen vermögen in einem jahr um sage
und schreibe 16 milliarden euro
gestiegen ist dass der
selbstverständlich einen angemessenen
anteil dafür das gemeinwohl zurück
führen müsste aber seit sie in der
regierung sind kein wort mehr von einer
vermögenssteuer und
bei dem knallen diese woche die
sektkorken so richtig genau bei den
aktionären der rüstungskonzern weil sie
an diesem freitag allen ernstes unser
grundgesetz ändern wollen um 100
milliarden schweres auf rüstungsprogramm
hineinzuschreiben seit der bloßen
ankündigung dieses auf rüstungsprogramms
ist der aktienkurs von rheinmetall
bereits um 100 prozent gestiegen merken
sie was 100 milliarden euro für rüstung
und das obwohl der wert bereits heute
bei 50 milliarden euro pro jahr liegt er
ist jahr für jahr gestiegen ist einfach
falsch dachte abgesicherte wurde jahr
für jahr ist er angestiegen trotzdem
behaupten sie die 100 milliarden wären
notwendig um die bundeswehr fit zu
machen
muss man klar zu sagen natürlich muss
die bundeswehr in der lage sein ihren
grund gesetzlichen auftrag die
landesverteidigung zu erfüllen aber dass
sie das heute nicht kann das liegt nicht
an zu wenig geld auch der
bundesrechnungshof sagt man müsse klären
ob nicht andere gründe ursächlich sind
für die mangelnde einsatzbereitschaft
zum beispiel strukturelle defizite bei
der organisation der bundeswehr wir
wissen doch das ist ein eklatantes
missmanagement gibt und das ist auch der
grund für die probleme nicht so wenig
geld dass die wahrheit
um es ganz klar zu sagen
dieses sondervermögen ist gegenüber den
millionen menschen in unserem land die
existenzielle sorgen und nöte haben
einfach eine unverschämtheit ich kann
das nicht glauben aber
auch vielen politisch ist es verheerend
eine aufrüstung spirale macht die welt
nicht friedlicher das wissen wir doch
das gegenteil ist der fall man dass die
union das die fdp mit so einer politik
keine probleme haben das keine
überraschung aber kolleginnen kollegen
von der spd sie kommen aus der tradition
von willy brandt kolleginnen und
kollegen von den grünen sie kommen doch
aus der friedensbewegung
100 milliarden euro für ausrüstung ins
grundgesetz schreiben das doch irrsinn
machen sie da doch nicht mit
der prinz
das würde ich auch einmal gegen
waffenlieferungen in kriegsgebiete zu
sein insbesondere gegen schwere
waffenlieferung das hat nichts mit
pazifismus zu tun wir haben das hier vor
kurzem einmal dargestellt hat es hat
etwas mit vernunft zu tun russland ist
die größte atommacht der welt der
militärischen mitteln ist dieser krieg
nicht zu gewinnen ist auch deeskalation
es braucht diplomatie es braucht
wirksamer sanktionen gegen die russische
führung gegen die mächtige oligarchen
damit möglichst schnell der krieg endet
dafür die mittel längst noch nicht
ausgeschöpft und das wissen sie auch
sie haben versprochen
unter ihnen ja ich weiß das hören sie
ungern ist aber die wahrheit sie haben
versprochen und eben als finanzminister
wird ist keine schulden geben keine
neuen schulden geben was sie hier aber
irreführend als sondervermögen
bezeichnen ist in wirklichkeit nichts
anderes ist sind neue schulden plötzlich
geht es für alles andere soll aber ab
2023 die schuldenbremse wieder gelten
diese schuldengrenze wegen der seit
jahren während der seit jahren immer
wieder heißt es sei kein geld da die
schuldenbremse wegen der städte und
gemeinden immer öfter schwierigkeiten
haben öffentliche schwimmbäder
bibliotheken jugendclubs oder sogar
frauenhäuser offen zu halten die
schuldenbremse wegen der verheerenden
einem investitionsstau gibt weil straßen
brücken und dem schienennetz von
schnellem internet will ich gar nicht
anfangen herr lindner sagt wir müssen an
unsere kinder und enkel denken deshalb
bräuchte es die schuldenbremse aber
das ist volkswirtschaftlich leider
völliger und denn selbst denn selbst die
sprichwörtliche schwäbische hausfrau die
angela merkel damals als kronzeugen für
die einführung der schuldenbremse bemüht
hat als sinnbild für eine ordentlich
wirtschaftende person selbst die
schwäbische hausfrau würde einen kredit
aufnehmen um ihr kaputtes dach zu
sanieren statt es einfach rein regnen zu
lassen insbesondere in sulz ins zeit
vergehen müssen
wer und enkel denken und deshalb dürfen
wir ihn doch kein verfallenes haus
hinterlassen das ist doch die wahrheit
kolleginnen und kollegen wir brauchen
investitionen für unsere zukunft zum
beispiel mit den konsequenten ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien und der habe
meinen sie eigentlich dass mit
progressiver politik wenn sie für
aufrüstung wenn sie auf brust und 100
milliarden bereitgestellt werden die
investitionen in erneuerbare energien
aber unter dem vorbehalt der
schuldenbremse stehen oder wenn sie ihre
umweltziele einfach aufgeben und sich
für fracking gas terminals einsetzen
oder zulassen dass das weltnaturerbe
wattenmeer durch gasbohrungen gefährdet
wird so erzählt es eigentlich ihren
wählerinnen schmieren rätsel ich denke
ich denke es ist klar geworden warum wir
diesen haushalt nicht zustimmen können
er ist nicht sozial und zutiefst
ungerecht und dazu können wir als linke
niemals jahr hin
amira nur mit ali von der linksfraktion
die kleinste oppositionsfraktion gm wohl
pause und auch sie hat der massive
kritik an der ampel regierung unter
anderem würden rentner studierende leer
ausgehen bei den entlastungs paket
gingen sie hat die vermögenssteuer
gefordert und die 100 milliarden für die
bundeswehr steht weckt natürlich
abgelehnt die linken sind gegen
waffenlieferungen in kriegsgebiete das
habe etwas mit vernunft zu tun die
eskalation und diplomatie seien jetzt
gefragt ist fdp-fraktionschef jahr
2022 also der staat diese
regierungskoalition steht unter
vorzeichen die wir uns vor fast genau
einem halben jahr während der
koalitionsverhandlung nicht hätten
vorstellen können nicht nur spüren wir
die wirtschaftlichen und sozialen
nachwirkungen des höhepunktes der korona
pandemie das alles drückt ja in den
hintergrund angesichts des
angriffskrieges russlands in der ukraine
und die schrecklichen bilder die wir von
dort täglich sehen die zerstörung und
das leid das wir dort sehen sind
schrecklich und jegliche unterstützung
die wir leisten ist richtig und
notwendig ich möchte daher an dieser
stelle noch einmal deutlich sagen egal
was wir tun wir dürfen uns an die bilder
aus der ukraine nicht gewöhnen meine
damen und herren wir dürfen uns diese
bilder nicht gewinnen
und wir reagieren indem wir geld an der
seite der ukrainerinnen und ukrainer
stehen die auch für die europäische
freiheit kämpfen wir unterstützen
finanziell ganz konkret den ukrainischen
staat damit er weiterhin von
funktioniert ganz konkret in diesem
bundeshaushalt abgestimmt mit den g 7
stellen wir eine milliarde zusätzlich
deutsche steuergeld zur verfügung um die
funktionsfähigkeit des ukrainischen
staates aufrecht zu halten auch das ist
ein wichtiges signal dieser
haushaltsberatungen über politik
und
wir schaffen etwas weiteres mit diesem
bundeshaushalt das ist ja schon viel
über stellen ausgesprochen worden beim
generalbundesanwalt der
bundesjustizminister beim
generalbundesanwalt schaffen wir stellen
für die verfolgung von kriegsverbrechen
meinen damen und herren diese
kriegsverbrechen in der ukraine dürfte
nicht ungesühnt bleiben wir werden die
täter verfolgen meine damen und herren
auch von deutschen und straffer grund
geben wenn wir also über diesen
bundeshaushalt sprechen in diesem jahr
sprechen wir über veränderte
gegebenheiten über eine geopolitisch
andere welt als noch vor zwei monaten
hier steht ja insbesondere das
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr im
fokus der bundeskanzler hat das hier
vorgeschlagen am 27 februar ich bin dem
bundesfinanzminister ausdrücklich
dankbar für seine verhandlungsführung
ich bin ihm dankbar dass er die
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion davon
abgehalten hat ja einen absurden
abziehen am freitag durchzuführen meine
damen und herren wir schaffen es mit
diesem sondervermögen die bundeswehr
endlich so auszustatten wie sie
ausgestattet werden muss die eine
moderne armee ausgestattet werden muss
das wurde in den vergangenen zwei
jahrzehnten sträflich vernachlässigt und
es dient nicht nur unsere eigenen
sicherheit sondern das sind wir endlich
auch den soldatinnen und soldaten der
bundeswehr schuldig meine damen und
herren um das auch klar zu sagen
ein zweiter punkt der mir in dem
zusammenhang mit dem sondervermögen
wichtig ist wir weichen nicht von der
schuldenbremse ab wir schleifen nicht
die schuldenbremse im grundgesetz
sondern wir werden am freitag mit zwei
drittel mehrheit dieses sondervermögen
beschließen was speziell der bundeswehr
zur verfügung steht und vor allen dingen
herr kollege merz wir erhöhen nicht die
steuern ich war heute morgen sicher dass
der oppositionsführer viele fragen
erneut stellen wird oder eigene konzepte
vorzulegen aber an einer stelle haben
sie mich belangt überrascht damit war
nicht zu rechnen
der spd vorzuwerfen
sie hätte den soli abschaffen müssen
damit sie jetzt als cdu csu den
vorschlag machen können den soli fahren
menschen wieder ernsthaft ein zuführt
wie absurd ist das denn meine damen und
herren das ist
politische kompetenz der cdu csu und
deutschland viele kollegen putin absolut
dosb ein absurder vorschlag ich hätte es
mir nicht folgen lassen ich hätte es mir
nicht träumen lassen
diese
bundesregierung herr merz diese
koalition ist mit einer doppelten
hypothek der 16-jährigen und jüngst
geführten bundesregierung gestartet
erstens eine vernachlässigte bundeswehr
sprach gerade darüber und andererseits
eine sehr gefährliche abhängigkeit von
russland bei der energie deshalb ist das
im koalitionsvertrag verankerte thema
planungs beschleunigung der wollen
planungs beschleunigung in deutschland
so voranbringen dass dir die planungs
und genehmigungsphase halbieren
dringlicher denn je hier sind wir in der
letzten sitzungswoche einen ersten
schritt gegangen mit dem ausbau von lng
terminals einen ersten wichtigen schritt
und ich schlage vor dass wir genau daran
anknüpfen sollten wenn wir darüber reden
dass die wirtschaft in den nächsten
jahren massive investitionen tätigen
muss dann darf das ja nicht jahrzehnte
dauern dann brauchen wir schnelle
verfahren in allen bereichen der
wirtschaft der industrie in deutschland
unterbauch bei die infrastrukturvorhaben
des staates meine da mut denn das was
wir hier vorgeschlagen haben das was wir
durch den deutschen bundestag gebracht
haben bei den lng terminals mit der mit
dem ziel der energieunabhängigkeit ist
ja geradezu eine blaupause für weitere
projekte meine damen und herren um die
transformation der wirtschaft nach vorne
zu bringen kaum ein land der welt ich
will dass zum thema klimaschutz an der
stelle sagen kaum ein land der welt hat
in den letzten jahrzehnten so viel geld
für klimaschutz ausgegeben aber so wenig
für klimaschutz erreicht meine damen und
herren das müssen wir umdrehen wir
brauchen auch planungs beschleunigung
damit wir energie unabhängig werden und
endlich den klimaschutz entsprechend in
deutschland voranbringen und die
transformation unserer volkswirtschaft
liebe kollegen
und
diese
diese ampel koalition ist angetreten um
das leben der menschen in deutschland zu
verbessern das mag erst pathetisch
klingen aber das ist jetzt sehr konkret
herz denn das was wir jetzt sehen dass
die letzten wochen und monate für viele
menschen sehr sehr hart gewesen sind und
leider wahrscheinlich nicht einfacher
werden ich denke an die millionen
familien mit kleinen ankommen die die
gestiegenen preise jetzt sehr deutlich
spüren und dennoch alles dafür tun damit
ihre kinder alles bekommen was sie
brauchen ich denke an die gastronomen in
unserem land die erst unter der pandemie
und jetzt unter einem enormen
personallage leuten ich denke an die
vielen handwerksbetriebe die weiteren
junge menschen ausbilden und die jeden
tag auf die lieferwagen und auf ihre
transporter angewiesen ich finde es
daher richtig dass wir es geschafft
haben in den letzten wochen so viele
entlastung auf den weg zu bringen um all
diese menschen zu erreichen wir haben
den kinderbonus erhöht die
heizkostenpauschale wird die
einmalzahlung in höhe von 100 euro für
transferempfänger die energie pauschale
in höhe von 300 euro für alle
erwerbstätigen die einführung des neuen
euro tickets wurde gesagt und die
senkung der steuern auf benzin und
diesel die höhen in der einkommensteuer
dauerhaft und rückwirkend zum ersten
januar den grundfreibetrag der
arbeitnehmerpauschbetrag und die
pendlerpauschale
meine damen und herren wir werden für
die unternehmen in deutschland das was
ich als damals nach haushalts und
finanzpolitiker in der opposition immer
gefordert habe nämlich den steuerlichen
verlust rückt dauerhaft auszuweiten wer
in der vergangenheit als unternehmer in
deutschland
solidarisch mit dem steuer start war
weil er oder sie gewinne gezahlt hat mit
dem muss jetzt auch der steuerstaat in
schwierigen zeiten solidarisch sein das
macht diese regierungskoalition
liebe kolleginnen kollegen
und wer entlasten gezielt und reagieren
angemessen auf die aktuelle
wirtschaftliche lage und die hohe
belastung der menschen in diesem land
heute tritt die senkung der
energiesteuern kraft um die pendlerinnen
und pendler zu entlasten und ich habe ja
die ersten meldungen dazu gesehen im
ersten schritt obgleich natürlich noch
alter alter bei altes benzin und 1 diese
sozusagen in den tank ist aufgrund der
damals höheren steuersätze trotzdem
sinken glücklicherweise heute morgen die
preise an den tankstellen wir müssen die
menschen im ländlichen raum weiter im
blick behalten
60 prozent der menschen in deutschland
wurden nicht in urbanen zentren sondern
sie wohnen im ländlichen raum das sind
viele pendlerinnen und pendler das sind
viele familien und diese
regierungskoalition erhält genau diese
menschen im blick auf das will ich an
der stelle deutlich sagen
und wir schaffen mit diesem
bundeshaushalt etwas weiteres über
bildung ist für meine begriffe noch zu
wenig gesprochen worden heute morgen
diese bundesregierung bringt eine große
bafög reform auf den weg und sie
finanziert sie auch und ich will eine
sind aller klarheit sagen weil das in
den letzten jahren ja ich muss das sagen
herr merz und die letzte
bundesbildungsministerin die über mich
kann philosophiert hat kam ja von der
cdu ich will das in aller klarheit sagen
wir müssen an einer stelle in
deutschland einer gerechtigkeitsfrage
den hebel umlegen die frage wie man im
leben voran kommt darf nicht vom
elternhaus abhängig sein sondern es muss
davon allerdings sein wie man sich
anstrengt im leben jeder muss den
gleichen chance haben und das tun wir
mit dieser waffe gefunden
und ich will deshalb insgesamt diesen
haushalt in ein verhältnis setzen wir
hören die investitionen um 50 milliarden
euro das sind bis zum jahr 2026
350 milliarden euro investitionen des
bundes mehr als jemals zuvor wir werden
die ausgaben für den bundeshaushalt
2022 um 77 milliarden euro
reduzieren und gleichzeitig machen wir
100 milliarden euro weniger schulden als
die große koalition
2021 wir setzen die richtigen
prioritäten und der bundeshaushalt
2022 ist der auftakt für den
bundeshaushalt des kommenden jahres
gehen wir hier in wenigen wochen bereits
diskutieren werden das ist der
unterschied zur unionsgeführten
vorgängerregierung und ich will das
sagen herr merz der immer mehr fordert
um gleichzeitig zu hoher ausgaben
kritisiert der passt nach meiner
rechnung an der stelle nicht zusammen
wenn es nach ihren vorschlägen und jetzt
will ich auf ihre arbeit während der
letzten wochen als opposition zu
sprechen kommen wenn es nach ihren
vorschlägen geht würden wir in diesem
jahr als koalition 60 milliarden euro
mehr schulden machen das ist doch die
wahrheit herr merz ich habe mir ihre
anträge im haushaltsausschuss sehr genau
angeschaut sie wollen 60 milliarden aus
dem energie und klimafonds einsätzen für
das was sie vorhaben also sie nutzen
eine rücklage von der sie selbst sagen
sie sei verfassungswidrig
das passt nicht ich frage sie welches
verfassungsorgan wollen sie hinter die
fichte führt das
bundesverfassungsgericht oder den
deutschen bundestag herr kollege merz
das müssen sie beantworten
und frage ich sie wo ist ihr plan zur
rückkehr zur schuldenbremse wo ist
eigentlich der plan der union um zur
schuldenbremse im kommenden jahr
zurückzukehren ich habe schon mal gesagt
und wiederhole es an dieser stelle gerne
die schuldenbremse ist bei christian
lindner und olaf scholz in besseren
händen als bei friedrich merz und
alexandra droben um das in aller
klarheit zu sagen
kollegen und
ich habe in der letzten beiträge öfter
gesagt dass meine oppositionsarbeit auch
so verstehen muss dass man service
opposition ist in dem man intelligente
vorschläge macht und auch alternativen
zur regierungsarbeit vorschlägt gerade
weil die öffentlichkeit aus meiner sicht
ein anrecht darauf hat herr kollege merz
diese 60 milliarden die schlank weg in
ihren haushalts vorschlägen stehen
fehlen jetzt stehen zwar drin aber die
fehlen in der sache die fehlen in der
sache weil sie selbst sagen das sei ja
verfassungswidriges geld stichwort
service opposition das was wir in den
letzten wochen bei den
haushaltsberatungen der cdu/csu erlebt
haben das ist keine service opposition
das ist eine einzige servicewüste
gewesen meine damen und herren da ist
nichts warum gekommen haushaltspolitisch
gar nichts von dem was sie da vorgelegt
haben und deswegen
will ich zum schluss ein wichtiges thema
ansprechen was sie auch angedeutet haben
von ihrem idol ein kollege der cdu csu
fraktion auch gestern bei der debatte
zur finanzpolitik um den einzelplan des
bundesfinanzministers nämlich die frage
der altersversorgung in deutschland
diese bundesregierung wird den
nachholfaktor in der rente wieder
einführen wir priorisieren im haushalt
so dass wir entsprechendes auch schaffen
in zukunft in richtung kapital der
kapitaldeckung bei der altersvorsorge zu
gehen und ich will ihnen das in aller
klarheit sagen ich bin da schon sehr
sehr verwundert herr merz sie sagen nach
16 jahren verantwortung bei der rente
sei es irgendwie gescheitert sie haben
die bundeskanzlerin gestellt mit verlaub
nein das ist nicht ich habe hier
gesessen für irland nicht an der spd
alles gescheitert es ist vor allem die
union gewesen die bis heute keinen
retten konzept vorlegen kann bis heute
haben die keinen vorschlag zu machen wie
es deshalb nicht und deswegen
will ich einen sehr konkreten
kürzungsvorschlag den sie vorgelegt
haben als fraktion auftreten
sie kürzen bei der beruflichen
integration für zuwanderer mag wie ein
kleiner titel erstmal klinge ich glaube
das ist ein verräterischer vorschlag
weiter innerhalb weit eine andere halten
stück da steckt eine andere haltung
dahinter beiden viel größeren thema ich
will in diese klare frage stellen
herbergs wollen sie mit dem historischen
fehler der eigenen partei aufräumen und
deutschland endlich zu einem modernen
einwanderungsland macht oder freunden im
wirtschaftlichen interesse unseres
landes es ist im größten nationalen
interesse der bundesrepublik deutschland
dass wir endlich ein modernes
einwanderungsland werden denn nur so
werden die die fachkräfte bekommen nur
so werden wir die renten der zukunft
absichern auf diese zentrale
zukunftsfrage die diese
regierungsfraktionen sich in die
koalitions vertrag ist haben sie nicht
eine einzige antwort heute geliefert
nicht in der vergangenheit hier handeln
ich danke
ist ja ein bürger der fdp
fraktionschef hat sich hier am schluss
noch mal an der durch märz und der union
abgearbeitet am anfang hatte gesagt
diese kriegsverbrechen werden nicht
ungeschehen bleiben wir werden die täter
verfolgen wir weichen nicht von der
schuldenbremse ab hat er noch gesagt und
wir erhöhen auch nicht die steuern und
wenn sie jetzt als letzten fraktionschef
den spd fraktionschef rolf mützenich
vermissen haben sie völlig recht aber
die spd hat eben mitgeteilt rolf
mützenich verzichtete zugunsten der
anderen redner denn der kanzler allzu
lang thorsten frei jetzt für die union
teil ihrer rede zeit darauf verwenden
die koalition die opposition zu
beschimpfen das ist sicherlich keine
zukunftsträchtige strategie wenn es
darum geht die herausforderungen der
zukunft zu lösen und zu bewältigen und
in der tat es sind wichtige zeiten in
denen wir stehen es gibt ereignisse die
zeilen die zeit in ein davor und ein
danach und der verbrecherischen
angriffskrieg russlands auf die ukraine
ist ein solches ereignis und deswegen
hatte herr bundeskanzler heute ja auch
sehr viel über die zeitenwende der
großen staaten gesprochen es gibt aber
zeitgleich auch eine zeitenwende der
kleinen leute und die beginnt nicht mit
einer kriegserklärung sondern die kommt
schleichend und lautlos daher die ist
unerbittlich und sie ist enttäuschend
für viele menschen und auch
existenzbedrohlich und diese zeitenwende
macht vor allen dingen rentner arbeiter
und sparer zu den großen verlierern
dieser zeit und diese zeitenwende heißt
inflation und sie
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
antworten darauf nur mit dem kurieren
von symptomen nicht indem sie die
ursachen der inflation der
geldentwertung bekämpfen und sie herr
bundeskanzler haben heute morgen gelobt
wie die rentensteigerung ausfallen wird
ja wir hatten im letzten jahr eine
geldentwertung von 3,1 prozent in diesem
jahr von 7,9 prozent das sind mehr als
zwei prozent als die rentensteigerung
die wir dieses jahr bekommen werden das
heißt nicht mehr für die menschen
sondern weniger in den geldbeuteln das
ist die wahrheit und darauf sollten sie
eine antwort finden in dieser situation
in dieser situation die gebe ich ihnen
gerne in dieser situation sind vor allen
dingen diejenigen getroffen die den
ratschlag vieler politiker in den
vergangenen jahren beherzigt haben
nämlich fürs alter vorzusorgen
aber in dieser situation schmilzt die
altersvorsorge der menschen hier in
deutschland wie eis in der sonne das ist
das ergebnis ihrer politik und ich will
an dieser stelle ich will an dieser
stelle meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren auch von den grünen ich will an
dieser stelle einmal den früheren
bundesfinanzminister
zitieren der hat nämlich im juni letzten
jahres also vor ziemlich genau einem
jahr folgenden satz gesagt zitat ich
will allen die sorge nehmen dass wir mit
der inflation ein allzu großes problem
bekommen die inflation wird viel
geringer und ganz normal ausfallen als
viele befürchten das hat der damalige
bundesfinanzminister vor einem jahr
gesagt und ich will ihnen nicht
vorwerfen dass sie anders als andere die
herr aufkommenden probleme nicht erkannt
haben dass sie sie weg geschrieben
hatten aber was ihnen vorzuwerfen ist
ist dass sie bis heute es nicht als
zentrale herausforderungen ihrer
kanzlerschaft begriffen habe etwas
dagegen zu tun dass das geld der
menschen mehr und mehr entwertet wird
das ist die herausforderung wenn sie es
täten dann würden sie eine andere
fiskalpolitik machen dann würden sie
insbesondere auf europäischer ebene nach
anderen regeln rufen sie tun es
allerdings nicht und deswegen sage ich
ihnen eines der kampf gegen die
geldentwertung das ist sozialer
verantwortung der kampf gegen die
geldentwertung das ist
leistungsgerechtigkeit und deswegen
fordern wir sie auf endlich dieses thema
auch anzugehen und zwar nicht
indem man an den symptomen herumdoktern
sondern indem man die ursachen bekämpft
und ich will vor diesem hintergrund noch
ein letztes zitat heute ansprechen es
stammt vom früheren
oppositionspolitiker und heutigen
finanzminister christian lindner er hat
damals über die inflation die er früher
als andere erkannt hat und den damaligen
bundesfinanzminister folgendes gesagt
zitat der staat attackiert lindner
scholz den er mit einem karnevalsprinzen
vergleicht ist einer der größten wenn
nicht der größte treiber von inflation
als finanzminister war olaf scholz mit
kamelle um sich und weiter die
öffentlichen finanzen solide zu halten
ist der wesentliche baustein der
inflationsbekämpfung wenn die ezb das
schlepptau der fiskalpolitik stark
verschuldeter staaten geraten würde dann
hätte sie kaum eine möglichkeit die
inflation zu bekämpfen
zitat ende und statt neuer schulden
müsste deutschland so lindner den zitat
tilgungs toro anwerfen also unsolide
staatsfinanzen schmettert lindner scholz
entgegen gefährden die preisstabilität
ich finde besser kann man es nicht
zusammenfassen und umso mehr fragt man
sich ob das wirklich der mann ist der
sechs monate später einen
verfassungswidrigen
nachtragshaushalt mit 60 milliarden
neuen schulden vorlegt die ganz sicher
auch vor dem bundesverfassungsgericht
scheitern werden ob das der gleiche ist
der zwölf monate später mit 240
milliarden euro nettoneuverschuldung die
höchste neuverschuldung in der
geschichte der bundesrepublik
deutschland zu verantworten hat meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren ich will
ihnen sagen es gibt etwas das schmilzt
noch schneller als das vermögen der
deutschen
und das ist die glaubwürdigkeit der fdp
sie schmilzt das eis in der sonne
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
und vor diesem hintergrund stellt sich
wirklich die frage
wir haben ein bundeskanzler der regiert
das problem und tut auch jetzt so als
gäbe es nicht wir haben ein
bundesfinanzminister der erkennt das
problem handelt aber gegensätzlich und
damit wird eines deutlich es ist das
muster ihrer koalition diese koalition
wird zusammengehalten durch schulden
schulden und noch mehr schulden es ist
der kitt dieser koalition damit wird
alles zugeschüttet aber was vielleicht
der zement für diese koalition ist es
sprengstoff für die glaubwürdigkeit der
fdp das sollten sie sich sehr gut
überlegen
und jetzt muss man jetzt muss man eines
sagen
in der ein oder anderen rede hat man den
eindruck gewinnen können dass
geldentwertung
schicksal wäre eine naturgewalt nein das
ist es nicht
die geldentwertung ist das ergebnis
politischer ökonomischer fiskalische und
geldpolitische entscheidungen und jede
einzelne dieser entscheidung kann man
auch anders zu treffen und ich will es
ihnen an drei beispielen benennen ja ich
werde interessant drei beispielen
benehmen natürlich stimmt es dass wir
den lock down in china haben dass wir
den krieg in der ukraine haben da haben
sie ja vollkommen recht dass wir eine
lokalisierung von produktionsstätten
haben dass wir die fiskalpolitik der
staaten haben und die geldpolitik der
europäischen zentralbank aber an drei
beispielen möchte ich ihnen zeigen dass
man es auch anders machen kann erstens
die verlagerung von produktionsstätten
ja es ist richtig sich aus russland
zurück zu ziehen und es ist auch richtig
in den blick zu nehmen dass wir
strategische abhängigkeiten von china
reduzieren oder gar beenden aber wenn
man das tut dann muss eine
internationalisierte volkswirtschaft wie
wir sie haben auch nach neuen räumen
ausschau halten und das bedeutet noch
mehr internationale zusammenarbeit mit
den staaten die unsere werte von
freiheit von demokratie und
rechtsstaatlichkeit teilen dann geht es
um staaten wie die usa und kanada und
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren c
a ist seit vier jahren ausverhandelt ist
ausgeurteilt vom
bundesverfassungsgericht seit wochen
bemühen wir uns in jeder einzelnen
sitzungswoche das ratifizierungsgesetz
ja im bundestag zur abstimmung zu
bringen wer verhindert es die koalition
verhindert es und es macht sie
unglaubwürdig meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren kollegen einheiten punkt
einer zweiten punkt völlig ansprechend
kollege frei ich habe die ruhe
angehalten gestatten sie eine frage das
heißt ich hatte sie angehalten
wir starten sie eine frage oder
bemerkung aus der grünen fraktion
lieber herr frey wir haben uns ja auch
letzte woche schon 40 minuten zum thema
inflation ausgetauscht und ich finde es
schön dass sie jetzt auch nicht nur die
symptome bekämpfen wollen sondern die
ursachen angehen wollen ganz
unumstritten liegen die ursachen an
unserer massiven klumpenrisiko haften
abhängigkeit von russischem gas die sie
uns hinterlassen haben 55% abhängigkeit
das muss man erstmal schaffen da sind
jetzt dran das zu lösen zweitens
energiemärkte die auch vom bmf und
kartellamt als populistisch bezeichnet
werden angebot und nachfrage regeln hier
eben nicht den preis ich wünsche mir
jetzt wir haben vor fünf minuten schon
gefragt dass sie uns damals lösungen
präsentieren da haben sie gesagt sie
wollen das machen bitte nennen sie uns
doch mal ihre lösungen für den
energiemarkt und dass diese preise die
übrigens auch ursachen für die
lebensmittelpreise in deutschland sind
und zwar massiv dass sie die das
auflösen würden was sie uns 16 jahre
kaputt gemacht haben vielen dank
bleiben sie basieren
sehr geehrte frau beck einen punkt habe
ich gerade eben erwähnt wenn es
beispielsweise um internationale
handelsverträge geht den zweiten punkt
will ich gerne ansprechen das ist auch
ein wesentlicher grund für die ursachen
für die ursachen der geldentwertung das
ist der angebotsschock den wir in europa
haben darauf hat übrigens die
europäische kommission reagiert indem
sie ermöglicht dass wir beispielsweise
auch beispielsweise auch aus
ökologischen brachflächen vorrangflächen
feldfrüchte anbauen können da könnte man
allein in deutschland
800.000 tonnen getreide anbauen mit
denen man drei millionen menschen
ernähren könnte alle länder in europa
praktizieren das einer ist dagegen herr
bundeskanzler ist es ihr
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister und
deswegen muss man sagen das ist nicht
nur ein beitrag um die probleme noch
weiter zu verschärfen sondern dass es
auch ein beitrag dazu nichts zu leisten
wenn es darum geht eine weltweite
hungersnot zu bekämpfen und ich will
einen
[Applaus]
vorbeck sie haben ganz konkret sie haben
ganz konkretes thema energie
angesprochen
ich frage mich wenn ich ihre pläne hier
im deutschen bundestag anschauen da ist
zum beispiel auch das roster paket dabei
ich bin ein abgeordneter aus dem
schwarzwald gibt es seit jahrhunderten
wasserkraft wasserkraft versorgt etwa
eine million haushalte in deutschland
mit energie regenerative energie die
aber anders als wind und sonne dann zur
verfügung steht wenn man sie wirklich
braucht und im ostpaket sind regelungen
drin die wasserkraftwerke für 90 prozent
der betreiber verunmöglichen und es
machen sie in einer zeit wo es darum
geht autark zu werden wo es darum geht
unabhängig zu werden da nehmen sie diese
möglichkeiten vom tisch genauso wie die
wie sie die letzten drei verbliebenen
atomkraftwerke ausgerechnet an dem tag
abschalten wollen wo wir wahrscheinlich
den peak der herausforderungen im
nächsten winter erreichen werden das ist
sicherlich keine kluge und
verantwortungsvolle politik und ich will
zum dritten sagten
natürlich ist für inflation vor allen
dingen auch die geldpolitik der
europäischen zentralbank entscheidend
dies ist unabhängig zu recht aber die
spielräume der europäischen zentralbank
die selbst in zeiten dieser inflation
noch negative einlagenzinsen und
anleihekäufe macht
dir diese handlungsspielraum ergibt sich
natürlich auch daraus wie die
fiskalpolitik der staaten aussieht und
da würde ich mir wirklich versprechen
dass sie einer sicherheitspolitischen
zeitenwende auch eine haushalts- und
finanzpolitische zeitenwende folgen
lassen dass die schwerpunkte setzen und
dass sie nicht jedes problem mit neuen
schulden lösen womit wir natürlich dann
auch eine negative vorbildwirkung in
ganz europa haben werden und dafür
bräuchten wir einen starken
bundesfinanzminister der als liberaler
eigentlich die ganzen linken
blütenträume aus dem koalitionsvertrag
herausstreichen müsste und dazu
bräuchten wir einen bundeskanzler der in
diesem zusammenhang nicht von einem
hamilton moment träumt der bundeskanzler
sie haben damals nicht die ganze
geschichte erzählt als es um die
verschuldung in europa ging als
alexander hamilton
1790 die vergemeinschaftung der schulden
in den usa
ermöglicht hat da hatte im grunde
genommen nicht den zement für den neuen
staat angehört sondern er hat
sprengstoff gelegt er hat viele staaten
in die insolvenz getrieben das waren
auswirkungen bis zum amerikanischen
unabhängigkeitskrieg bis zum großen
krieg der staaten und es ist etwas das
wollen wir mit schulden sind keine
zukunftspolitik in deutschland nicht und
in europa nicht und sie sollten eine
politik machen die dazu führt dass wir
auch in europa die regeln einhalten die
wir uns gegeben haben die es dann
ermöglichen dass wir tatsächlich auch
kraftvoll gegen inflation und
geldentwertung vorgehen können
herzlichen dank
thorsten frei der parlamentarische
geschäftsführer der cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion
der bundestag debattiert am zweiten tag
der haushaltsdebatten hier in der
sogenannten generaldebatte
und der nächste redner wird von der spd
kommt achim post stellvertretender
fraktionsvorsitzender
präsidentin meine damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
ehrlich gesagt fragen wir nach den
beiden reden von herrn merz und herrn
frey den ich sehr schätze wie sie wissen
muss man eigentlich alles negieren was
man in 16 jahren regierungszeit gemacht
hat kann man auch kann man auch regieren
dass man selbst für die größte
nettokreditaufnahme in diesem lande
bisher verantwortlich war und es jetzt
den anderen in die fugen weil meine
position ist ist das nicht vielleicht
ein bisschen wenig ist das nicht
vielleicht unterkomplex wenn ich das mal
fragen darf
wenn du über diesen haushalt reden liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
dann hat
diese ampel koalition diese
bundesregierung dieser
bundesfinanzminister
und die fraktionen diese ampel einen
haushalt vorgelegt einem guten haushalt
vorgelegt einen guten und
verantwortbaren haushalt vorgelegt und
dieser haushalt liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ist auch dringend notwendig in
zeiten wie diesen denn mit diesem
haushalt gewährleistet diese koalition
diese bundesregierung dieser
bundeskanzler dieser
bundesfinanzminister dass wir es
hinbekommen was für die äußere
sicherheit für die innere sicherheit und
für die soziale sicherheit gleichzeitig
zu tun denn diese drei dinge gehören
zusammen die kolleginnen und kollegen
ja es stimmt
dieser haushalt hat ein hohes volumen
495 milliarden euro das ist viel geld
das weiß ich es gibt gründe dafür ich
nenne mal ein paar der erste grund ist
die korona pandemie mit der wir uns seit
zwei jahren auseinander setzen müssen
und die noch nicht zu ende ist liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen und die bei
erfordert dass wir betrieben und
beschäftigten helfen und diese koalition
wird das auch machen liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
und es gibt einen zweiten wurden
putins angriffskrieg der
auswirkung hat nicht nur für millionen
von menschen in der ukraine für viele
tote er hat auch auswirkungen auf uns
auf deutschland auf europa und auf die
welt und das ist keine petitesse liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen sondern das ist
eine zeitenwende von der wir alle zu
recht hier geredet haben und deshalb
will ich mal eins sagen ich glaube das
ist richtig ist ich weiß dass es richtig
ist dass wir uns geeinigt haben in
dieser zeitenwende auch das
sondervermögen bundeswehr und zwar die
ampel zusammen mit der größten
oppositionsfraktion mit der cdu/csu und
ich weiß das zu schätzen dass wir
gemeinsam diese zeitenwende mit einer
antwort versehen nämlich mit einer
starken bundeswehr und wenn ich mal
etwas sagen darf zur kollegin mohammed
ali zur linken wenn sie willy brandt
zitieren das dürfen sie gerne machen das
den dürfen dort gerne denn sie dürfen
alles mit willy brandt machen was sie
möchten aber ich darf auch darauf an
formen und ich möchte darauf antworten
willy brandt ist der falsche kronzeuge
gegen das sondervermögen denn willy
brandt hat den friedensnobelpreis
bekommen für eine werte geleitete
realpolitik mit der aussöhnung mit dem
osten mit mit der summe damaligen
sowjetunion mit den anderen ländern
osteuropas und er diesen
friedensnobelpreis bekommen weil er das
gemacht hat auf der grundlage
einer starken verankerung in der nato im
westlichen bündnis und in der
europäischen union die bundeswehr hatte
damals 500.000 soldatinnen und soldaten
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
also
keine falschen kronzeugen so
ich merke der kollege
wohl bewusst
es tut mir leid ich muss sie erstmal
geschäftsleute eingreifen sind sie
bereit eine frage oder bemerkung des
kollegen in horten zu bekommen
danke
kollege dass wir das so die lateral
klären aber wir warten natürlich auf die
präsidentin ich möchte sie fragen weil
sie einen kurzen exkurs zu willy brandt
gemacht haben da wäre ja schon meine
frage wenn wir in die historie zurück
rücken insbesondere die
auseinandersetzung die auch der von mir
sehr verehrte willy brandt mit dem
nachfolger helmut schmidt geführt hat wo
es ja insbesondere um die aufrüstung
ging teilen sie meine einschätzung dass
willy brandt insbesondere für die
damalige friedensbewegung eine sehr
große rolle gespielt hat wo sich nämlich
explizit gegen die aufrüstung stark
gemacht hat unter anderem mit heinrich
böll und vielen anderen und deswegen
dazu meine frage finden sie deswegen
nicht das was meine
fraktionsvorsitzenden zurecht ausgeführt
hat dann doch historisch treffen als das
was sie gerade entgegnet haben
lieber kollege also ich weiß nicht ob
man es besser macht wenn man jetzt noch
einen anderen äpfel und birnen vergleich
hinzufügt ich glaube das eine mit dem
anderen nichts zu tun deswegen bedanke
ich mich für die zwischenfrage aber ich
glaube dass sie mehr oder weniger
sinnlos rausfinden
und jetzt kommen wir jetzt können wir
ein sondervermögen
was ist das was ist das gute am
sondervermögen dass deutschland das die
bundesregierung reagieren ob die
zeitenwende dass wir uns wehrhafter
machen dass wir unsere bundeswehr besser
ausstatten und gleichzeitig über die
konstruktion des sondervermögens dafür
sorgen dass in anderen bereichen waren
klimaschutz in der bildungspolitik in
der sozialpolitik nicht gekürzt wird
liebe kolleginnen kollegen und das ist
ein ganz hohes gut eingangstor wert des
genau die richtige politik
und das was ich gerade gesagt habe über
die politik von willy brandt und helmut
schmidt dass sie eingebettet ist ins
westliche bündnis das gilt doch auch für
die bundesrepublik deutschland das galt
auch schon zu zeiten als sie regiert
haben liebe kolleginnen und kollegen von
der cdu csu und das gilt erst recht für
diese ampel koalition für diese
außenministerin für diesen bundeskanzler
vor diesem bundesfinanzminister und für
alle anderen die da sitzen denn das was
wir machen folgt einem grundmuster das
grundmuster heißt koordinierung und
kooperation wir koordinieren und
kooperieren innerhalb der europäischen
union innerhalb der nato und mit unseren
transatlantischen partnern und anderen
freundinnen und freunden in der welt und
genau das ist die richtige haltung um
außen und friedenspolitik zu machen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und wenn wir und wenn wir darüber reden
was wichtig ist für deutschland dann
will ich auch mal gerne was sagen wir
müssen hier in deutschland darüber reden
dass wir natürlich wir haben über die
äußere und die innere sicherheit geredet
auch über die soziale sicherheit gerade
in zeiten wie diesen wen und ich gucke
mal rüber zur regierungsbank zu wertes
heil ich kann für meine fraktion mich
nur bedanken beim bundesarbeitsminister
dafür dass er zwölf euro mindestlohn
einführt und das ab dem ersten oktober
millionen von menschen von diesen
mindestlohn profitieren
und wenn ich das mache habe ich eine
frage an die kolleginnen kollegen von
der cdu csu erst waren sie gegen den
mindestlohn ganz grundsätzlich immer
ganz grundsätzlich vor den letzten
landtagswahlen hatte ich den eindruck
sie waren dafür ich kenne auch viele
zitate wie zum beispiel der jetzige
ministerpräsident wüst gesagt hat er sei
für die einführung eines mindestlohns
von 12 euro jetzt höre ich dass sie am
falter sich enthalten wollen was für ein
machtvolles dokument der hilflosigkeit
liebe kollegen und kollegen wunder
cdu-kollege post sie können natürlich
weiter sprechen nicht macht hierbei
überhaupt aufmerksam dass es jetzt auf
kosten ihrer nachfolgenden kolleginnen
und kollegen tun da ich das dann sah ich
dass da ich das nie machen beende ich
meine rede mit einem ganz klaren hinweis
diese bundesregierung dieser
bundeskanzler diese ampel koalitionen
sind gut für deutschland ich bin stolz
darauf dass olaf scholz unter
bundeskanzler ist und niemand der da
vorne sitzt sollen dank
achim post mit einer feststellung die
folgerichtig war denn er ist
stellvertretender fraktionsvorsitzender
der spd alles andere wäre ja auch sehr
wunderlich gewesen aber auch er hat
seine redezeit sehr strapaziert wie vor
ihm schon der bundeskanzler deswegen hat
er rolf mützenich aus seiner rede
verzichtete das findet hier immer so
einen gewissen ausgleich wenn einer
überzieht muss der andere redezeit
abgeben aus der fraktion wohlgemerkt
tino kubala der fdp fraktionschef
22 zu verabschieden wir beraten in
dieser woche über eine neuverschuldung
in
schwindelerregender höhe von circa 139
milliarden euro damit wachsen die
geplanten ausgaben auf nahezu 500
milliarden euro ein werter herr
bundeskanzler
wann konnten sie als regierungschef
dieser ampel koalition eigentlich einen
arbeitstag mit dem gewissen beenden
unser land vorangebracht zu haben denn
eines muss ich sagen die verantwortung
für die desolate lage unseres landes
lastet zu recht schwer auf ihren
schultern
als ehemaliger bundesfinanzminister und
sozialdemokrat haben sie ihre
vorgängerinnen über jahrzehnte den boden
für eine realitätsferne wirtschafts und
finanzpolitik gegeben und wir erleben
hier und heute den wirtschaftlich und
sozialen abstieg deutschlands und seiner
bürger und wie ist ihre reaktion darauf
entweder hört und sieht man den
bundeskanzler nicht oder man hört von
einem ehemaligen bundespräsidenten dass
man auch martin frieden führen können
und genau das ist unwürdig meine damen
und herren unwürdig dem land gegenüber
führt dass sie als bundesregierung
verantwortung übernommen haben und vor
allem unwürdig den menschen gegenüber
die tagtäglich zur wertschöpfung in
deutschland und damit zum wohl unserer
gesellschaft beitragen
die cdu steht im übrigen nichts nach sie
haben ja selbst in der ard vom ende
unseres wohlstandes für eine gewisse
zeit gesprochen für mich hört sich das
so an als hätte die cdu deutschland
bereits aufgegeben und den glauben an
sich selbst verloren denn lösungen haben
die christdemokraten heute und auch sie
herr merz nicht hervorgebracht sie haben
kein wort zu den deutschen bürgern
gesagt kein wort zu den steuerzahlern in
diesem land meine damen und herren diese
beiden politiker bringen heute ihre
eigene ernte ein schauen sie sich in
unserem land um sie werden die
ergebnisse fehlgeleitete politik der
letzten jahrzehnte überall erkennt der
mann durch unser land wirkt diese träten
immer stärker in den vordergrund und
lassen sich auch nicht mehr vertuschen
beispielsweise wurde der spalt zwischen
den struktur stärken und den
strukturschwachen regionen sogar noch
vertieft und wir alle wissen für kaum
ein unternehmen des mittelstands ist es
wirtschaftlich überhaupt noch attraktiv
sich in einer strukturschwachen region
dauerhaft niederzulassen
hier hat der deutsche staat seit jahren
seine grund aufgabe nicht erfüllt und
die heißt aufbau und erhalt von
infrastruktur verkehrsnetze von straßen
und schiene breitbandausbau
gesundheitsversorgung und bildung sind
nur einige eckpfeiler die einfach
vorhanden sein müssen es ist die aufgabe
der regierungen in den ländern und auch
im bund die grundlegenden
voraussetzungen schaffen damit gerade
auch kleine und mittelständische
unternehmen und insbesondere das
handwerk existieren können aber was ist
eigentlich
was ist eigentlich ihre idee für
deutschland und den kontinent europa in
den nächsten 20 jahren wehrt die
bundesregierung wie werden wir nach der
sogenannten energiewende leben und
arbeiten wie geht es weiter dazu
schweigen sich komplett aus damit endet
die einseitige utopie der ampel
koalition meine damen und herren welche
industrien beispielsweise werden noch in
deutschland existieren und welche
während wir entwickeln müssen womit
werden die menschen in diesem land ihr
geld verdienen wer wird in diesem land
eigentlich überhaupt noch wertschöpfend
arbeiten zu diesen fragen hören wir
schon lange keine antworten mehr
verdienen sie fahren mit ihrer politik
nur noch auf sicht und weiter was sollen
wir den nachfolgenden generationen was
würden sie ihren kindern eigentlich
raten welchen beruf sie erlernen welches
studium sie ergreifen sollen wir sehen
die berufsbilder der zukunft eigentlich
aus investition in das team investieren
sie überhaupt noch einen gedanken in
dieser wichtigen frage stellung wir und
viele deutsche bürger jedenfalls können
das aktuell nicht erkennt ihre politik
werden die bundesregierung schafft
deutschland und europa als
eigenständigen und zukunftssicheren
wirtschafts und bildungsraum vollkommen
ab
und nicht genug
nicht genug versuchen diese
bundesregierung seit jahren die
strukturellen probleme mit neuen
staatsschulden zu lesen natürlich auch
in diesem haus halten als alternative
für deutschland haben wir stets und
ständig darauf hingewiesen dass sie
unser land damit in einer installation
hinein steuern und auch hier sollten wir
recht behalten meine damen und herren
die steigenden preise für die waren des
täglichen bedarfs und kraftstoffe haben
die bürger ihnen zu verdanken und sie
sollten sich wirklich schämen die
ergebnisse ihrer mangelhaften politik
mit dem deckmantel des ukraine krieges
verhüllen zu holen sie alle hier wissen
sie alle hier wissen
dass die notenpresse der ezb seit jahren
auf hochtouren läuft um die missstände
zu verschleiern und genau das ist der
hauptgrund die geldmenge in europa
und dazu kommt noch jetzt das
beschlossene bemerkung auch das wird uns
hier in europa schwächen in den
erdölraffinerien von schwedt und lena
werden arbeitsplätze und in den regionen
dadurch die wirtschaftskraft verloren
gehen ideologisch verblendet beharrt
diese bundesregierung seit monaten auf
ihren standpunkten und ebenso lange
machen wir sie ausdrücklich die
einsparpotenziale aufmerksam sie jedoch
sind in einen ehrlichen kassensturz gar
überhaupt nicht interessiert einnahmen
ausgaben gegenüber stellen ist nicht
gewollt dabei werden es möglich dass sie
über 100 milliarden euro bei der energie
und klimafonds bei der auflösung der
jury klage oder einer ordentlichen außen
und entwicklungspolitik im deutschen
interesse einsparen könnten auch das
bürokratiemonster eu darf nicht weiter
unbedacht gefüttert werden würde man nur
einen teil dieser vorschläge in erwägung
ziehen könnten wir den staatshaushalt
entlasten und viel mehr wäre dieses geld
volumen auf frei ja auch für die
finanzierung der bundeswehr ohne neue
schulden aufzunehmen und ohne das
grundgesetz zu ändern oder um in die
chronisch unterfinanzierten sozialen
sicherungssysteme zu investieren das
sind sie nämlich den bürgern schuldig
die einen großteil ihrer einkommen jeden
monat dafür auf in und damit den
sozialstaat auch aufrecht erhalten
aber diese bundesregierung reagiert wie
gewohnt nachdenklich und könig zunächst
einmal ein entlastungspaket an das hört
sich natürlich auch immer toll und schön
an nicht nur das ist lange auf sich
warten lässt hat man sich zuallererst
einmal den ideologischen klima baukasten
bedient und versucht mit einem neuen
euro ticket die bürger über die
sommermonate von ihren autos weg hin zum
psv zu bringen natürlich können wieder
nur diejenigen davon profitieren bei
denen noch busse und bahnen fahren
wieder werden nämlich die infrastruktur
schwachen regionen abgekoppelt und dann
kommt sie gerne vor hasselmann meinen
wahlkreis nach görlitz er fährt pro
woche ein bus da können sie dann fahren
einmal 49 euro das ist der grund die
menschen dort haben rein gar nichts von
dieser kurzfristigen symbolpolitik sie
sind zur eigenen versorgung wenn ich auf
ihr auto angewiesen
und hiervon besonders betroffen sind
ausgerechnet die älteren und ältesten
unserem land ausgerechnet diejenigen
denen wir unseren wohlstand zu verdanken
haben die in unser land aufgebaut haben
die werden zum dank für den regierungen
gedemütigt und auch vergessen aber
gerade diese menschen brauchen unsere
unterstützung verdient unsere
wertschätzung und auch entlastungen
haben diese menschen verdienten ja die
preisspirale dreht sich immer noch
weiter hohe kraftstoffpreise werden
höhere lebensmittelpreise zur folge
haben die erzeugerpreise liegen schon
über den handelsreisen ergreifen sie
endlich pragmatische lösungen die bei
den bürgern und unternehmen auch
ankommen setzen sie die mehrwertsteuer
auf grundnahrungsmittel ausschaffen sie
entlastung bei der lohn und
einkommensteuer durch anhebung der
grundfreibeträge und noch einmal die co2
abgabe gehört abgeschafft
und auch wir selbst hier im deutschen
bundestag müssen endlich die
wahlrechtsreform vorantreiben hätte
dieses parlament die angemessene zahl
von 598 abgeordneten anstelle der 736
würden wir pro jahr 100 millionen euro
einsparen das würde zum vertrauen der
bürger in unsere parlamentarische arbeit
und in die politik beitragen und könnte
sich vielleicht sogar positiv auf die
wahlbeteiligung auswirken wahrscheinlich
wollen sie das aber gar nicht nette
kollegen ein weiter so tanzen und dann
bis zum schluss kommen letzter satz
präsidentin werte kollegen ein weiter so
kann und darf es nicht mehr geben wir
brauchen eine politik in der unsere
bürger ebenso zuerst gedacht werden wie
deutschland vielen dank
der bundestag debattiert über den
kanzler der
die generaldebatte ist das und zu diesem
kanzleretat gehört auch der bereich
kultur und medien und die zuständige
staatsministerin im kanzleramt claudia
roth hat jetzt als nächste das wort
krieg ist ein zustand bei welchem die
niedrigsten und lasterhaften menschen
macht und ruhm erlangen das sagte lew
tolstoi in diesen düsteren zeiten leben
wir und so ringen wir um die richtigen
antworten unsere koalition das parlament
genauso wie die menschen in unserem land
wir alle ringen um richtige antworten
denn genau das zeichnet doch eine
demokratische politik aus wir stellen
uns den aufgaben offen mit all unseren
zweifeln und mit den notwendigen
diskussionen denn es gibt sie nicht die
einfachen antworten
in diesen zeiten haben wir den
absolutheitsanspruch des krieges etwas
entgegenzusetzen
die demokratische meinungsbildung und
unser unterscheidungsvermögen das ist
auch aufgabe der kultur und
medienpolitik
ich werde mich in zwei wochen mit den
medien minister/innen der g7 treffen und
wir wollen uns zu drei ganz zentralen
punkten verständigen was können wir tun
um für das gesellschaftsmodell der
demokratie zu werben was können wir tun
um propaganda und desinformationen
entgegenzutreten
und was können wir tun um diejenigen zu
schützen die dem demokratischen streit
und der freien meinungsbildung
verpflichtet sind und genau deswegen aus
ihren herkunftsländern und besonders aus
russland fliehen müssen
journalistinnen sind fachkräfte der
demokratie deswegen haben wir zusammen
mit dem aaa ein programm zu ihrem schutz
aufgenommen und kämpfen mit anderen
ressorts gegen desinformation was wir
nicht brauchen sind kultur boykotte und
die kulturalisierung von konflikten es
ist putins krieg und nicht puschkins
krieg die freiheit von kunst und kultur
zu verteidigen das ist grundlegende
aufgabe von kulturpolitik und das sage
ich auch und gerade mit blick auf
aktuelle debatten liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen lassen sie mich vier beispiele
benennen wie wir den kulturellen
zusammenhalt in unserem land stärken
erstens wir kümmern uns um die
künstlerinnen und künstler erst
vorgestern habe ich gemeinsam mit
hubertus heil und ich mit
kulturschaffenden ausgetauscht es geht
jetzt um einen konkreten arbeitsprozess
ihre soziale lage zu verbessern von der
künstlersozialkasse über formen der
selbstständigen beschäftigung von
mindestlohn oralen dem gender pay gap
bis zur altersvorsorge
es ist wichtig dass das zukunftsprogramm
neustadt bis mitte nächsten jahres
fortgesetzt werden kann wichtig mit
blick auf die weiteren anhaltenden
risiken und folgen der korona krise mit
denen die kulturszene ja nach wie vor zu
kämpfen hat zweitens wir wollen eine
breite in die zukunft gerichtete
erinnerungspolitik die erinnert an die
verbrechen des nationalsozialismus die
erinnert an das sed-unrecht die erinnert
an den kolonialismus und mit der
rückgabe von benin großen richtige
zeichen setzen wird eine erinnerungs
politik aber auch in und für die
einwanderungsgesellschaft
rechtsextremismus antisemitismus
rassismus sie zeigen doch ihre hässliche
fratze von melun bis solingen von halle
von halle bis hanau eine lebendige
erinnerungspolitik muss und wird darauf
antworten geben müssen und diese
erinnerungspolitik wird europäisch sein
deswegen habe ich meine erste
auslandsreise nach frankreich
unternommen und sie muss ein deutliches
zeichen gegen den antisemitismus und für
unsere freundschaft mit israel setzen
und deswegen war ich auf meiner zweiten
reihe in der vergangenen woche in israel
und habe mit dem israelischen
kulturminister eine verstärkte
zusammenarbeit verabredet drittens wir
wollen die vielfalt von kunst und kultur
und medien in unserem land fördern es
geht um den erhalt der kinos vor allem
im ländlichen raum um eine preis für
plattenläden und bibliotheken und museen
als dritter orte um wichtige
institutionen der musikalischen bildung
es geht um den film festival verband
scope um den bundes musikverband chor
und orchester um das jugendballett und
um so viel mehr nicht zuletzt geht es
darum die vielen einrichtungen und
bauten in ihren wahlkreisen zusatz zu
erhalten und zu sanieren und sie instand
zu halten
viertens
das alles wird nur gelingen wenn wir
nachhaltigkeit als voraussetzung von
freiheit verstehen ohne nachhaltigkeit
werden zukünftige generationen keine
freiheiten mehr haben das ist also
unsere verantwortung auch in der kultur
und medienpolitik und mit dem green
culture können wir einen entscheidenden
beitrag gegen die dramatische klimakrise
leisten wir wollen kunst und kultur mit
allen und für alle ermöglichen indem wir
ihre vielfalt und ihre freiheit sichern
und verteidigen all dies ist möglich
dank ihrer unterstützung liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen zum einen durch
die fachpolitiker innen ich nenne
stellvertretend für alle die vorsitzende
des kulturausschusses katrin budde und
zum anderen heute ganz besonders die
haushaltspolitiker namentlich otto
fricke dennis rohde andreas auftritt
aber eben auch kerstin radomski und
gesine lötzsch
in düsteren zeiten
wir müssen uns darauf einstellen wir
müssen lösungen erarbeiten wir müssen
handeln und lassen sie uns deshalb kunst
kultur und medien in freiheit in
gerechtigkeit und in nachhaltigkeit
erblühen vielen dank claudia roth ganz
begeistert warum ganz einfach der kultur
etat wird um sieben prozent erhöht auf
2,29 milliarden euro neben verschiedenen
dingen gibt es unter anderem auch geld
für projekte die zur erinnerung an
anschläge der jüngsten zeitgeschichte in
deutschland stärker ausgebaut werden
sollen hierfür sind es 1,7 millionen
euro vorgesehen otto fricke der
haushälter der ticken was mit dem
vertrauen innerhalb dieser koalition zu
tun hat und das ist die tatsache dass
wir gar nicht mehr darüber reden dass
wir die frage der alt kanzler in einer
sehr eleganten wie ich finde und das
möchte ich noch mal sagen zu meinen
sprecher kollegen kindler und rode in
einer sehr eleganten weise gelöst habe
dieser haushaltsausschuss diese
koalition ist im haushaltsausschuss in
der lage komplizierte probleme zu lösen
und ich danke dafür dass du das
geschafft haben was viele ja gedacht
haben was uns nicht gelingen würde
meinen dank möchte ich habe dann
meinen dank möchte ich aber auch dann an
den kollegen haase richten die da oben
beim kollegen märz sitzt der sich jetzt
bayern hat sie sicherlich entschuldigt
dafür dass er ihn nicht erwähnt hat bei
der frage wie wir beim sondervermögen zu
lösungen kommen auch das möchte ich dann
sagen das ist haushalts arbeit an der
stelle dafür zu sorgen dass man so etwas
hinbekommt und kollege haase ohne ihre
arbeit an der stelle wäre das nicht
gelungen dass wir heute nachmittag heute
abend so hoffe ich ein vernünftiges
ergebnis finden werden meine damen und
herren
ich hätte mich auch gerne bei der linken
bedankt wenn sie da konstruktiv
mitgearbeitet hätte ja meine damen und
herren meine damen und herren ich will
das ausdrücklich noch mal sagen auch war
ja jetzt noch ein großteil des kabinetts
anwesend ist die frage wie wir mit dem
haushalt gegenüber der regierung umgehen
hat auch etwas mit der frage zu tun wie
ein selbstbewusstes parlament der
regierung sagt was es von der regierung
erwartet und wo es notwendigkeit in der
veränderung sieht das hat etwas zu tun
mit der frage wie geht man mit kaffee
vermerken um das hat was mit der frage
mit von selbst wirtschaftens mit dem zu
tun was ich alles sehr sehr schlecht
anhört aber es ist liebe regierung die
frage der bindung an den parlaments und
da bitte ich auch in den nächsten jahren
sehr genau darauf zu achten denn im
haushaltsausschuss in verbindung mit den
fachausschüssen werden dinge erarbeitet
die manchmal eben doch viel näher am
menschen am bürger an der bürgerinnen
dran sind als das was ein
ministerialbeamter in sicherlich guter
fachlichkeit denkt und deswegen hören
sie öfters aufs parlament gerade beim
haushalt kann das von vorteil sein meine
damen und herren zum kulturbericht nur
eine sache noch ergänzt claudia roth hat
ja in einer großen linie all die dinge
gesagt die sie wollte die wir wollten
die beschlossen worden ist und ich
möchte eine sache für den bereich kultur
hervorheben die sich eigentlich im
einzelplan des kollegen halbe findet
nämlich im einzelplan 11 die
künstlersozialkasse ich bin als
liberaler sehr glücklich darüber dass es
uns gelungen ist für die künstler an der
stelle eine größeres maß an sicherheit
schaffen wo sie in den letzten jahren
ganz besonders betroffen waren nämlich
bei der frage ihrer altersvorsorge hier
danke ich allen beteiligten dass sie ich
sag das mal so wünschen und anregungen
die auch ein wenig aus der reihe den
reihen der fdp kamen nach gegangen sind
und wir eine lösung finden die wir ja
dann noch gesetzlich ergänzen so sollte
politik in der ampel funktionieren weil
sie auch dafür sorgt dass kultur nicht
nur funktioniert sondern
kulturschaffender auch soziale
absicherung haben das ist ampel mein
name ist herren ich muss aber dann
ich muss aber ganz zum schluss doch noch
mal zur cdu/csu kommen herr frei der ist
glaube ich jetzt schon nicht mehr daher
frei hat eben gesagt ja warum
kritisieren sie uns na ja ich muss
einfach sagen eine solche opposition in
haushaltsverhandlungen habe ich noch nie
erlebt ich muss gebe einfach mal nur
dinge durch sie sagen an der stelle
kürzungsanträge für die
öffentlichkeitsarbeit der
bundesregierung die diese koalition
stellen wir kürzen öffentlichkeitsarbeit
unserer regierung wo wir sagen das ist
zu viel sagt die cdu die regierung
braucht mehr geld bei der frage
300.000 euro für ein konzept
wirkungsorientierte haushaltsführung
sagte sagt die cdu csu das braucht man
nicht wirkungsorientierte
haushaltsführung ist für uns nicht
wichtig bei der frage
künstlersozialkasse die ich gerade
erwähnt habe stimmt die cdu dagegen und
jetzt das neueste projekt der
haushaltspolitik der märz soli also man
wundert sich dann an der stelle schon
welche art von oppositionspolitiker
warten dann muss man eben liebe
kolleginnen kollegen von der cdu csu
dann doch damit rechnen dass das nicht
funktioniert und dass sie dann noch
angegangen werden inhaltlich hier und
ein letztes
warum gelingt ihnen denn eigentlich
keine richtige kritik und
oppositionspolitiker und das habe ich
gestern wieder beobachten können es ist
doch ganz einfach so bei ihm wenn man
mit den haushältern redet hört man
folgenden satz na ja unsere
fachpolitiker die wollen ja alle viel
viel mehr geld ausgeben und die lasten
wir auch einfach und ihr problem ist um
es mit matthäus 537 zu sagen statt
shakespeare kollege wurde ihre rede ist
nicht ja ja ihre rede ist auch nicht
nein nein sondern was sie machen ist sie
wollen auf der einen seite stetig mehr
ausgaben haben können auf der anderen
seite aber überhaupt nicht darstellen
wie sie diese finanzieren wollen und die
krönung das muss ich auch sagen war dann
für mich und damit möchte ich dann auch
schließen die krönung war für mich die
drucksache 14 10 wo ja märz sie immer
sagen das wäre ja alles gar nicht so mit
diesen 60 milliarden die sie als
angeblich verfassungsfähigkeit das heißt
hier unter dem antrag der cdu csu
einnahmen dem haus ein achtung einnahmen
aus der rücklage und dann schreiben sie
rückabwicklung des vorgehens beim
zweiten nachtragshaushalt 20 21 in höhe
von 60 milliarden ja das heißt sie
nehmen etwas von dem sie sagen herr merz
es sei verfassungswidrig es sei wichtig
das übrigens überhaupt noch nicht
aktiviert ist das noch überhaupt nicht
ausgegeben muss dieses geld nimmt die
cdu csu um ihre wünsche und ihre träume
davon wie man mehr geld ausgeben kann zu
nutzen das ist keine oppositionspolitik
sondern das ist etwas wo der rest besser
schweigen ist herzlichen dank
otto fricke der haushälter der fdp hat
es früher noch mal angesprochen zum
anfang seiner rede die verhandlungen
über das sondervermögen gehen heute
abend in den ausschüssen weiter die
union hatte da offensichtlich bei der
verwendung der mittel noch nachfragen
damit ist immer noch nicht ganz geklärt
ob es zur abstimmung kommen wird am
freitag wie das
jawort
der wirtschaftsplan so aufgestellt und
erklärt wurde dass die union dieser
zweidrittelmehrheit diese
zweidrittelmehrheit bei der umstellung
des 100 milliarden sondervermögens im
grundgesetzen mittragen wird jedenfalls
heute abend also die ausschusssitzungen
dazu vielleicht sagt ja eigentlich lange
von der union der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende auch etwas zu
diesem thema
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
ich will mit etwas bedienen was mich
seit einigen wochen und monaten doch ein
bisschen verwundert liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen insbesondere der spd lieber
kollege post sie haben etwas vorher als
unterkomplex bezeichnet ich bezeichne
ist als unterkomplex wenn eine fraktion
von 24 jahren 20 jahre regiert oder
mitregiert hat und dann ein
bundeskanzler sich hinstellt und mit dem
finger auf andere zeigt herr
bundeskanzler
das ist unter dem niveau eines kanzlers
dieses landes der auch zur politik der
vergangenheit er mitgestaltet hat stehen
sollte warum sage ich dass wenn es um
die verteidigungsminister geht erinnere
ich doch mal anfing und struck wenn es
um die finanzminister geht erinnere ich
an lafontaine eickel steinbrück und
scholz und wenn es um
sozialminister geht an alles holz
münteferings mit clement riester und so
weiter liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wir haben zusammen regiert sie haben mit
den grünen regiert wir haben wir mit der
fdp regiert haben wir die wehrpflicht
übrigens abgeschafft jeder hat hier
verantwortung für dieses land und hat
diese verantwortung entsprechend
getragen
was uns allerdings jetzt belastet aus
den letzten sechs monaten dieser neuen
regierung ist eine ganz schöne neue
verschuldung wie sie die bundesrepublik
deutschland nicht gekannt hat bisher und
dann nützen die rechentricks nichts
lieber kollege lindner 140 milliarden
neuverschuldung
60 milliarden zweiter nachtragshaushalt
und ein sondervermögen heißt zwar
sondervermögen man nennt es auch
euphemismus letztlich sind es schulden
mit denen das hier finanziert wird unter
dem strich 300 milliarden 300 milliarden
schulden das ist mehr als adenauer
erhard kiesinger brandt mit uncool bis
1990 zusammen gemacht haben und solide
und solidarisch unverantwortlich liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
niemand
niemand bestreitet dass
mit corona und dem russischen überfall
auf die ukraine wer eine ganz besondere
situation haben aber zum glück hat die
union seit
hart gearbeitet für diese schwarze null
und ein fundament geschaffen dass wir
überhaupt in der lage sind das zu
leisten was wir uns jetzt geleistet
haben in den letzten monaten
lebe lieber kollege lindner ich habe
vorgestern die interview im heute formal
gesehen und das war schon wirklich
beachtlich da reden sie zum einen dass
die schuldenbremse eingehalten werden
muss reden auf der anderen seite dann
dass man sich an schulden machen gewöhnt
habe da meinen sie wohl ihre beiden
koalitionspartner
und gleichzeitig erklären sie zur
schuldenbremse 20 23 zurückkehren zu
wollen
gleichzeitig verkündet der herr
sozialminister ein klima geld und wir
haben wir es vorhin beim beifall beim
thema klima geld gesehen tosende applaus
ein bisschen applaus kein applaus sowas
nenne ich zerfalls koalition liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
solide solide haushaltspolitik
solide haushaltspolitik ist ein
fundament für
generationengerechtigkeit
denn andere die generationen nach uns
müssen sonst das ausbügeln was wir jetzt
machen und ersatz hat einfach richtig
keit auf schuldenbergen können kinder
nicht spielen und liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen in der jetzigen phase der
aktuellen inflation wird das ganze noch
viel brandgefährlicher und das wissen
sie wir hatten schon mal in diesem land
eine station koalition in den 70er
jahren
auch daran möchte ich erinnern denn wer
darunter zu leiden hat sind die
mittleren und kleineren einkommen das
sind die rentnerinnen und rentner
und genau an dieser stelle stehen wir
und deswegen brauchen wir solidität
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
die einhaltung der schuldenbremse lieber
finanzminister darin werden wir sie
messen denn man hat manchmal das gefühl
sie wären in dieser koalition gerne der
neue ludwig erhard geworden tatsächlich
drohen sie zum neuen hans eichel zu
werden um das ganze würde ich dann auch
entsprechend im nächsten jahr wieder
kommentieren wollen liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
wir hatten vorhin kommen die
widersprüchlichkeit einerseits offene
märkte andererseits kein
freihandelsabkommen mit kanada
einerseits brauchen wir gas andererseits
sollen die stadtwerke die gasnetze
zurückbauen wir haben lieber
schaffts minister auch eine
widersprüchlichkeit wir geben ihnen
recht
regionale erzeugnisse sind positiv der
wochenmarkt ist etwas positives
all das ist richtig aber trotzdem droht
der welt in manchen teilen eine
hungerkatastrophe
und deutschland hätten sicherlich nicht
allein davor aber jeder hektar fläche
der angebaut wird für die
lebensmittelversorgung ist in einer
solchen situation ein gewonnener und wir
haben kein misstrauen gegen unseren
bauern und gegen und über unseren
landwirten wir haben vertrauen und sagen
danke für die nahrungsmittelsicherheit
die wir hier bei uns haben
zeitenwende ein schlagwort das seit ein
paar wochen
die diskussion prägt und inzwischen
ersetzt bei wikipedia zu finden ist aber
außer dem boot haben wir eher das gefühl
einer ruhigen hand vor allem dann wenn
es um die waffenlieferungen an die
ukraine gehen und die ruhige hand lieber
herr bundeskanzler die scheinen sie sich
ja von ihrem letzten spd-vorgänger
abgeschaut zu haben der in einem ganz
besonderen verhältnis ja auch zu
russland und putin steht unsere
verbündeten setzen auf uns das sagen sie
uns jeden tag wenn wir dann allerdings
lesen was der polnische staatspräsident
du da sagt oder der letzte außenminister
landsbergis dann sehen wir das genau das
hier nicht zutrifft diese
geschlossenheit die wir brauchen diese
waffenlieferungen die die ukraine von
uns zu recht erwarten kann liefern sie
nicht
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
liebe liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
niemand kann sich aussuchen was für
zeiten er oder sie lebt niemand kann
sich aussuchen wie man in einer solchen
situation vorab umgeht aber
zeitenwende bedeutet besondere
verantwortung
zeitenwende bedeutet für uns dass wir
gemeinsam mit unseren europäischen
partnern und konstruktiv die politische
ordnung in europa neu gestalten und den
vielfältigen krisen und
herausforderungen
stellen
nicht gegeneinander
das haben wir als union in den letzten
wochen auch als opposition deutlich
unter beweis gestellt aber auch nicht
ideologie getrieben sondern mit klarem
verantwortungsbewusstsein liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen unserer
fraktionsvorsitz hat heute drei fragen
gestellt an sie herr bundeskanzler
die bevölkerung hat einen anspruch auf
antworten wir werden sie an diesen
antworten hier messen dankeschön
ulrich lange war das meine damen und
herren die nächste rednerin kommt aus
dem kanzleramt nämlich die
staatsministerin für migration
flüchtlinge und integration
aller bali radovan von der spd
[Applaus]
kollegen der haushalt und die politik
der koalition sprechen eine klare
sprache
wir wollen mehr fortschritt und respekt
mehr sicherheit um zusammenhalt für alle
ob mit oder ohne einwanderungsgeschichte
ob geflüchtet oder her gekommen zum
arbeiten oder studieren 16 verschlafene
jahre
integrationspolitik holen wir jetzt nach
mit einer klaren agenda für teilhabe von
anfang an für ein modernes
einwanderungsland so knallhart bekannte
gegen das es muss das ist der neuanfang
in der integrationspolitik
dafür zwei beispiele hinterlegt in
meinem postfach erstens belegen im kampf
gegen rassismus endlich richtig nach die
straftaten sind gezählt die probleme
bekannt erst gerade vom national
diskriminierung und rassismus monitor
benannt 90 prozent der repräsentativ
befragten sagen ja es gibt rassismus in
deutschland
aber die große mehrheit will rassismus
entgegentreten mit widerspruch im alltag
mit demonstration mit ehrenamtlicher
arbeit als anti rassismus beauftragte
der bundesregierung werde ich diese
aufgabe erstmals mit einem
haushaltstitel in höhe von acht
millionen euro angehen dafür danke ich
besonders den kolleginnen kollegen des
haushaltsausschusses wir brauchen beste
hilfe vor ort von polizei und
sicherheitsbehörden aber auch und
unabhängigen beratungsstellen da ist
noch viel luft nach oben auch
strukturell darum will ich die
bestehenden beratungsstrukturen vor ort
stärken und dafür sorgen dass ihre
arbeit deutschlandweit bekannte und
erreichbar ist das ist richtig denn die
auch beratungsstellen helfen allen
individuell und persönlich die rassismus
erleben gemeinsam mit der
zivilgesellschaft mit den
migrantenorganisationen mit der
wissenschaft mit den ländern und
kommunen mit verbänden wählten wir
schauen wo die lücken noch offen sind
und wir werden diese schließen wir
dürfen die betroffenen von rassismus nie
wieder alleine lassen
auch die erinnerungen darf nicht
verblassen das schulden wir den
hinterbliebenen der nsu morde den
anschlägen vom seligs von solingen
münchen halle hanau den angehörigen von
marwa el sherbini den menschen die vor
30 jahren in rostock lichtenhagen um ihr
leben gefürchtet haben sie sind
unvergessen und
allein
und alleine diese aufzählung und das was
wir heute wieder aus der ganz rechten
ecke des saals gehört haben zeigt wir
haben ein problem und das werden wir
jetzt angehen
weiter und wir brauchen integration am
tag eins für alle die hier leben zur
eingewandert und geflüchtete auch für
800.000 menschen die gerade aus der
ukraine zu uns geflogen sind wir täten
gut daran viele der positiven
erfahrungen die wir gerade machen auch
für andere menschen zu nutzen dass das
chancen aufenthaltsrecht wird dafür eine
gute gelegenheit sein für eine gute
aufnahme aus der ukraine sorgen in
diesen wochen auch die vielen
ehrenamtlichen in den kommunen vor ort
sie verdienen unseren großen respekt und
dank aber es darf nicht bei worten
bleiben deshalb unterstütze ich die
ehrenamtliche koordination mitunter hand
und 20 millionen euro in meinem haushalt
wir lassen die ehrenamtlichen nicht
alleine
abschließen noch in aller klarheit
jeder cent den wir für integration und
anti rassismus arbeit im bundeshaushalt
investieren zahlt sich doppelt und
dreifach aus das ist eine investition
für unseren zusammenhalt für ein
friedliches miteinander für unsere
demokratie vielen dank
soweit die beauftragte der
bundesregierung für migration
flüchtlinge und integration gut drei
millionen euro möchte die
bundesregierung
mehr für flüchtlings projekte ausgeben
nächster redner es martin erwin renner
auf die fraktion das präsidium
kunst und kultur wir dürfen zwingend der
freiheit ist diese freiheit nicht
vorhanden dann wird kunst und kultur
ganz schnell zur vorgegebenen
auftragsarbeit artikel 5 unseres
grundgesetzes garantiert die freiheit
von kunst und kultur aber das wissen sie
ja alle hier im hohen hause sind ja
alles experten in politik demokratie und
recht ganz unverhohlen werden kunst
kultur und medien im us-haushalt der
subkultur begeisterten frau roth immer
massiver auf modernen bock ismus
getrimmt und immer schön das control
mainstreaming das diversity management
und den gender dadaismus betonen
doch hat das noch viel mit unserer
deutschen kultur und seine förderung zu
tun meinen wie denn auch wenn man schon
immer gerne in der transparenten
hinterherlief auf denen steht nie wieder
deutschland oder wenn man einen
ampelmann zum kollegen hat der doch
etwas mit deutschland anzufangen wusste
und es bis heute nicht weiß oder wenn
man eine kollegin in der abend bedeutet
gemeinschaft hat die eine spezifisch
deutsche kultur jenseits der sprache
schlicht nicht identifizieren können
ausgebeutete steuerzahler hat die
einigen kultureller und künstlerischer
freiheit zu alimentieren unter sowie
ideologie getränkten vorgegebenen
parametern wie geschlechtergerechtigkeit
diversität entwicklung
multikulturalismus klimaneutralität
vorgegeben innerhalb der kultur der
kunst medien und natürlich auch
vorgegeben der allgegenwärtige kampf
gegen rechtsextremismus rassismus der
vom kulturmarxismus
angeblasen und aufgeblasene um geistige
popanz unserer zeit was früher das
durchaus strittige kunstprojekt war ist
heute der klimabeauftragte
der die planungen die durchführung eines
kunstprojektes zu überwachen hat oder
die anlaufstelle greencard für die
beratung von kultureinrichtungen zu
fragen der ökologischen transformation
wer dagegen auf regiert der ist nicht
länger nur ein orden und kulturbanausen
ein er ist auch ein nicht zu
tolerierende rechter denen es mit allen
mitteln zu bekämpfen gilt sie und ihre
politik aber nicht nur im bereich der
kultur und in den medien sondern überall
unüberwindbare ideologie membranen uns
dann hier diese membranen sondern
demokratische freiheit vor augen doch
diese membranen sind nur mit einem
zeitleisten kultur marxistischen ungeist
durchlässig und wer die trecker themen
ihrer sozialistischen global istrischen
am politik unterstützt dessen
futtertröge werden durch das füllhorn
des steuerzahlers bossi anna singend
gewöhnt auf diese weise basteln und
werken ab so hyper moralische ampel habe
jung weiter an einer neuen gesellschaft
die die mehrheit der bürger gar nicht
haben will und sie das handy läuft also
deutlich erkennen dass dieser
andersdenkenden teil unserer
gesellschaft für sie gar keinen wert
mehr hat ich rate ihnen umkehr also
metanoia ist dringend notwendig
dankeschön
herr abgeordneter und ende
ich mache sie darauf aufmerksam dass wir
hier eine verabredung und regelung haben
dass die amtierenden präsidenten bzw
präsidentinnen auch in dieser weise
gewürdigt werden da geht es nicht um die
person sondern tatsächlich um die würde
des gesamten parlamentes insofern habe
ich jetzt darauf verzichtet ihre rede zu
unterbrechen und die anrede welche nicht
korrekt war zu rügen weiß auch auf hin
das sollte es sich im laufe des tages
noch einmal ereignen sicherlich die dann
amtierenden präsidentinnen und
präsidenten ob die entsprechenden
maßnahmen können
dienstags vizepräsidentin petra pau hat
hier noch mal darauf verwiesen
normalerweise sprechen für die
rednerinnen und redner auch immer die
bundestagspräsidentin oder die
entsprechenden vizepräsident hinein an
nächster redner ist nun andreas dresch
führen müssen und sich die grünen im
bundestag
präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren bernd wir hier sprechen
sterben in der ukraine menschen und
werden von einem autoritären einem
rechtsextremen diktator mit größter
brutalität in die flucht geschlagen
viele von denen viele hunderttausend von
ihnen kommen zu uns hier nach
deutschland und wir haben da eine
riesige aufgabe und es ist richtig dass
wir uns dieser aufgabe annehmen und vor
allem vor dem hintergrund dessen was in
den letzten wochen in den rechtsextremen
netzwerken zu dieser frage unterwegs war
ist es mir ein anliegen mit größter
überzeugung zu sagen es ist richtig dass
wir diesen menschen die sozialsysteme
öffnen ist es richtig dass wir diesen
menschen unseren arbeitsmarkt öffnen
beratungen geben und es ist darüber
hinaus richtig dass wir eben etat von
rema labbadia gewann 3 millionen euro
extra einstellen und projekte und
programme voranzutreiben die an der
stelle helfen das ist gut investiertes
geld
und ich möchte
ergänzen ganz explizit den großen dank
an christian doerr dass er das gerade so
deutlich gemacht hat wir werden den
historischen fehler der union den der
über jahrzehnte hier in deutschland ein
problem warnt nicht machen wir werden
den menschen in zukunft geben und sie
werden teil dieser gesellschaft und wir
werden alle davon profitieren
der krieg in der ukraine ist auch ein
krieg gegen die freiheit des denkens
gegen journalistin journalisten gegen
die liberale demokratie die uns so
wichtig ist claudia roth hat es gesagt
wir werden dieses thema auch zum g7
thema machen weil es auf dieser ebene
gehört aber wir warten nicht darauf wir
machen jetzt exil programme für
geflüchtete für kultur und medien
schaffende die von hier aus triebs
kriegstreibern sagen dass wir weiterhin
für demokratie für freiheit auf der welt
eintreten wir stärken die deutsche welle
mit über 13 millionen euro um freie
medien freies denken in diese welt zu
tragen und das ist die botschaft auch
aus der kulturpolitik hier in
deutschland wir werden für die liberale
demokratie streiten in deutschland und